أغلب الناس عندهم مشكلة بالرقبة
لما تأخذ تاريخهم، فوق الـ 50% منهم
يذكر أن صار حدث نفسي أو استماعي أو على مستوى الوظيفة، قوي
ومن بعدها بلشت تطلع آلام الرقبة
سيدة عندها آلام بالرقبة والكتف
لما أخذنا التاريخ، لقينا أنها تزوجت قبل الألم
وعلاقتها الزوجية زينة، وكل شيء
وانتقلت إلى المدينة الجديدة، وغريبة عليها
وكانت خايفة أنها تترك أهلها، وبلشت المشكلة
أهلًا، هذا فنجان من ثمانية، وأنا عبدالرحمن أبو مالح
كيف تعيش بدون آلام جسدية
حياتنا اليوم ليست كما عاشها أجدادنا أبدًا
تخيل اليوم أنك عشان تتحرك تدفع فلوس، وتشترك في نادي رياضي
بينما كان هذا النشاط والحركة جزء من حياة الإنسان الطبيعية
ومع الجلسة الطويلة، وعلى الجوال، والحركة المحدودة
كيف ممكن نعيش بصحة حركية أفضل؟
كيف نقي أنفسنا من مشاكل الظهر والرقبة والقدم والرقبة وغيرها؟
هل في جلسة صحيحة تقي من هذه المشاكل عند الكِبَر؟
فالحلقة مع ضيفي أمير الداغر
هو أخصائي علاج حركي، مُهتم بالصحة الحركية للإنسان
من الحركة حتى التنفس
فقد تكون هناك مشاكل وآلام في جسمنا
حلها لا يتطلب وجود طبيب، وإنما ضبط آلية التنفس عندك
قبل أن نبدأ
عندي إيمان بأن جزء كبير من سعادة الإنسان مُرتبط برضاه عن حياته
وجزء كبير من هذا الرضا يعتمد على نمط حياته اليومية
اللي ينعكس أثره على صحته وعلاقته وعمله
عشان كذا، أطلقنا في ثمانية نشرة بريدية جديدة
وهي نشرة نمط يكتبها لك الصديق العزيز «البراء العوهلي»
المتخصص في تصميم نمط الحياة
اشترك في النشرة، وانتظر العدد الأول السبت المقبل
رابط الاشتراك في وصف هذه الحلقة، أما الآن لنبدأ
اللي أتذكر في، ما أدري وين سمعتها
أتذكر حلقة قديمة في بودكاست ما
كانوا يقولون: أن الإنسان اليوم يلبس الجزم، وهو المفترض أنه ما يلبسها
لم يُخلق ليلبس جزمة، وشيء يمسك رجله طول الوقت
كانت النصيحة اللي طلعوا فيها بالنهاية
كان كلهم دكاتر وباحثين في القدم
أنك لا تلبس جزمة، وحاول أنك تكون حافي ما استطعت
أغلب الوقت، صحيح
وأن القدم، تدري هذه، لأن أتذكرها، وأنا جالس أكيّس الحين
أن القدم زي اليد، تقدر تسوي فيها كل شيء تسويه بيدك
اللهم أن احنا ما نمرّرها
إلى حد ما، صحيح
والله؟
إلى حد ما، الإبهام، عندك إبهام في القدم
أنت لاحظت أني أنا أسوي كل الحركة هذه، بس رجولي ما، يدوبك
تقدر مع الوقت، تشوف الناس، سبحان الله
اللي مبتورة إيده، شوف شلون يستخدم قدمه
القفشة والشوكة عادي عنده، يلبس نفسه بقدمه عادي طبيعي
تشوف على تعليقك على موضوع القدم
أن حضارات أو خلنا نقول: القبائل الحين في إفريقيا مثلًا الماساي
يلبسون، بس مو، أعزك الله، جوتي نفس مفهومنا الحالي
يلبسون مثل النعال
حتى في قبيلة في المكسيك اسمها «تراهومارا»
هذه معروفة بأن من نقطة ألف إلى باء يروحونها ركض
القبيلة اللي تركض، هذه اسمها
فمتعودين الركض حافي، أو الحد الأدنى، شيء جدًّا خفيف
فأبوه يرسله البقالة، يركض
يركض إي ما عنده، ليش بلشت سالفة الركض؟
هم مسالمين، أي أحد هجم عليهم قاموا ركضوا
فدخّلوهم هذا، لأنه يركض واجد
قال: خلنا ندخلهم سباقات ماراثون
هذا يروح عشرين أو ثلاثين أو أربعين كيلو ما عنده مشكلة، باليوم
وتغذيته على ماء شعير فقط
فلما حطّوا لهم أحذية، لا، صار عندهم إصابات
قدمهم مو متعودة أبدًا
فكله على التعود، وعلى أنت تعطي قدمك البيئة اللي تبيها وتحتاجها
فالحين ممكن أنا إذا قلت لشخص: اركض حافي
تجيه إصابة على طول، لأنه مو متعود
قدمه ضعيفة، تحتاج شوية بطانة على أساس يستمر
من ناحية العلماء، أن أنت تستخدم الحذاء، وللا لا؟
في خلاف على ذلك، دائمًا يقول لك: لا تسوي نقلة فجأة
تروح من حذاء فيه خمسة أو ستة بطانة إلى صفر، راح تؤذي نفسك
لأن التغيير المفاجئ في أي شيء، راح يؤدي إلى مشاكل أو إصابة
أحس الزبيرية يعني النعال ممكن تكون مفيدة
لأنه تخلي رجلك مكشوفة، وللا؟
نعم إلى حد ما، والأصابع تأخذ راحتها ما هي مضغوطة
لأن ضغط الأصابع هو المشكلة
نعم
تخيل الكعب العالي هذا
أكثر بواجد
يالله
هو صارت مسألة جمالية أكثر من أي شيء ثاني
أول ما بلشت ألبس الفيفو، اللي هو من قدام عريض، في 2017 بهالشكل
الناس كانت لما أدخل النادي تطالعني بنظرة غريبة
أنه هذا ليش لابس جوتي بولينق؟
أنه من الأمام عريض
مع الوقت صار في تقبّل، الحين الكل يلبس الفيفو ويمدحه
لما فهموا الفكرة
اللي يشيلون أوزان وغيره، تلاقي أن في ثبات أكثر في الأرض
لأن ما في شيء بيني وبين الأرض، فتصير
مع الوقت لما تروح هبة أو موضة الأحذية الضيقة، وأنه مبوّز من قدام
راح تشوف أنه منتشر، والناس ترتاح أكثر
الحين صار في تقبل، خلنا نقول أزياء
شوي شوي، إن شاء الله، يصير معنا
قبل نبدأ الحلقة، واحنا نبحث عنك، وفي الإعداد، كان في تحدي
كنا نقول دارس هندسة
صح
فصار قلق، وخوف أن نقدم أحد ما عنده
خلفية طبية
إي ما هو طبيب أو معالج طبيعي، ما عنده شيء يخليه يتكلم
صح
فوتّرتني السالفة، بس سألنا كثير، والكل يمدحك
زين أهم شيء
بس
أيش النقلة؟
وهل عادي أن الواحد يكون ما درس، ويقدم كل هذا؟
طبعًا، هل واحد عادي يكون دارس علوم الحاسب، ويقدم بودكاست؟
نفس الفكرة
ارتباط الهندسة بالحركة جدًّا عميق
في تخصص كامل اسمه الميكانيكا الحيوية
الـ (Bio) اللي هو حيوي، و(mechanics) ميكانيكية الحركة
فلقيت كمية الهندسة
خاصةً مادة، المهندسين أكيد يعرفونها اسمها السكون والديناميكية
اللي هي شلون تقيص المبنى، والضغط اللي عليه
والديناميكية هي حركة الأشياء من ناحية التأثير أو قوة أو زوايا
موجودة في الحركة
فتقيس، مثلًا أنا شفت جمال الحركة والهندسة في الحركة
ما بين علاقة مثلًا الورك مع الركبة مع القدم
وأبدعت، الحمد لله، في فهمها أسرع من غيري
فلما نروح دورات، يكون معنا أخصائيين علاج طبيعي ودكاترة وغيره
أشوف استقبال المعلومة أسرع
وهذه البداية كانت، خلنا نقول: عن تجربة شخصية
أنا مريت في إصابات، وما لقيت حل
الحلول التقليدية ما جابت أي نتيجة
بس لما اتجهت إلى مدارس مؤسسينها مهندسين
أو مصممي أزياء أو مدرسين إنقليزي
هذول الثلاثة من المدرسين، هم ملهميني
لقيت فرق واجد كبير، على قدمي وكتفي وتنفسي، وكل شيء
فالشغف يأخذ الشخص إلى الاتجاه اللي يبيه
وأنا ما أجيب شيء من عندي
أخذت أسس من مدارس تسمح لغير المتخصصين أو عندهم خلفية طبية
أن يمارسون العلاج الحركي أو الميكانيكا الحيوية
أحس أن الفرق هنا
أن مجالك اللي بنتكلم فيه كل اليوم، هو له علاقة بصحة الإنسان والطب
نعم
فهذا المكان ما يسمح بالشغف
عادةً يجب أنك تكون آخذ الأشياء اللي الناس متعودة عليها
أنك تدخل في المجال الأكاديمي كما هو
فهل في أطباء يقولوا لك: أن اللي جالس تسويه خطأ؟
أكيد
فأيش ردك عليهم؟
في رد أو في خلنا نقول رفض من الأطباء
وفي قبول من أخصائيين العلاج الطبيعي
في واجد أخصائي العلاج الطبيعي يرسلون مرضاهم لي
لأن بالنهاية في مزيج ما بين العلاج والتدريب
وأنا كل اللي أسويه أحاول أوازن الجسم كثر ما أقدر
وهذا العامل الهندسي
في شغلات خارجة عن، أو فوق مستواي التعليمي، فوق تخصصي
هذا أرجعه إلى أخصائي أو دكتور أو أيًّا كان
ولما تقول: أخصائي حركة، أيش تقصد فيها؟
أخصائي حركة هي مظلة تجمع عدّة مدارس
وهي استخدام الحركة أو يسمونها علوم الحركة
وانتقال الإنسان من نقطة ألف إلى باء، وحركة المفاصل
في أني أعالج الإنسان أو أرد الاتزان إلى جسمه
فما هي مدرسة وحدة، هي مسمى عام لعدّة مدارس معنية
في أني أنا شلون إذا شخص فقد الاتزان في الورك أو القدم أو أسفل الظهر
شلون أعيد له هذا التوازن مع الوقت
وأيش الفرق بينها وبين العلاج الطبيعي؟
هي جزء من العلاج الطبيعي
تشوف واجد في أخصائيين حركة حيوية يكونون أخصائيين علاج طبيعي
وفي لا، مثلًا دارسين علم الرياضة أو هندسة أو أيًّا كان
أو نظام لياقة بدنية، أيًّا كان
فالعلاج الطبيعي أكبر، ينقسم إلى علاج يدوي وحركي
والعلاج الحركي في مدارس تحته، والعلاج اليدوي أيضًا
وهل تشوف أن أغلب الناس صحتهم الحركية جيدة؟
لا
والله؟
نعم، لأن الإنسان خُلق أنه يتحرك
احنا خلنا نأخذ أول مرحلة
أو من أوائل المرحلة في نمو الإنسان، المدرسة
أنت في المدرسة ثمانية ساعات قاعد
صح
بعدين يشتكون، ليش هذا الولد شيطان؟
هو مو شيطان، هو طبيعته أنه يتحرك
فأنت أخذت مخلوق طبيعته أنه يتحرك، وحطيته بكرسي ثمانية ساعات
أيش متوقع؟
لذلك طلعت مدارس، مثل المونتيسوري والمدارس الأخرى
اللي تعتمد على شغف الطفل، وفضوله مع طبيعته الحركية
فتلاقي أن ما في مكاتب وطاولات
الطفل يروح من محطة إلى محطة، يتعلم اللي يبيه، يتبع فضوله
بعدين تروح أنت للجامعة اللي هم أربع أو خمس سنين من الجلوس
وأنا إنسان حركي
بعدين تنتقل إلى الوظيفة ثلاثين أو أربعين سنة إلى التقاعد
بعدين تتفاجئ، أنا ليش عندي مشاكل؟
وأنت خذيت الإنسان خارج بيئته، حطيته ببيئته اللي صممتها
وبعدين تشتكي ليش في مشاكل
فطبيعي، أن أنا إذا ركنت سيارة خمس سنين
لما أشغلها راح تكون مجيمة، راح يكون يبي لها صيانة وشغل
ما راح تكون نفس السيارة اللي شغالة دائمًا، فنفس المنطق
شلنا الإنسان من بيئته الطبيعية، حطيناه في بيئة اصطناعية
فطبيعي أن حركته ما راح تكون سليمة
بس مو الإنسان، صح أنه يحب يتحرك؟
بس برضو الحركة تتعبه، فهو يجد في الجلسة راحة
نعم، تصميمنا حاليًا للحياة منطقي، بالنسبة لي
بمعنى احنا الحين متّجهين إلى الذكاء الاصطناعي
ومتجهين إلى كل شيء يكون أسهل وأبسط على الإنسان
لأن مشكلة الإنسان الأساسية من سنين، هي بالطاقة
أنا ما عندي مصدر طاقة، لازم أبحث عن أكلي، وعلى أساسه أتحرك
ما أتحرك عبث، أتحرك لهدف
يا إما أروح أشوف أكلي، أو أنحاش من مكان
يا أن تغير الجو، فلازم أنقل لمنطقة
رحنا وغيرنا العالم كله، وصار الحين كل شيء متوفر لي
فليش أتحرك؟ ما لي هدف للحركة
فعلًا، الحين أنا وإياك، ليش نتحرك؟
في سيارة تأخذني وتجيبني
صح
في الإعداد كنا نتكلم عن سالفة أن الإنسان كسول أو ما يحتاج للحركة
شيء طبيعي
لأن الإنسان بطبيعته يبي يطلع أكبر مجهود بأقل طاقة
صح
بس الحين صار في وفرة من الطاقة، فطبيعي أقعد
فالحين صار علينا أن احنا نفكر بمنظومة أكبر
هنا الهندسة وتصميم المُدن تدخلان
فنشوف المدن اللي فيها حركة دائمًا، اليابان
المدن اللي فيها مترو أو طبيعة، حركتهم سليمة أكثر منا
يمكن يعمرون أكثر منا
لأن تصميم المدينة صار وفقًا لطلب الإنسان
أنا أروح من نقطة ألف لنقطة باء، لأن عندي شغل
وأروحها مشي، فهي صديقة للمشاة، وصديقة...
بالضبط، بعدين أروح العصر باستراحة الغداء مشي، عشر دقائق
والعشاء نفس الشيء، وأرجع بالقطار
فأكون مخلص أنا الـ10 أو 12 ألف خطوة بكل أريحية
فمو من المنطق أطلب من إنسان عايش مثلًا بالكويت أو السعودية
أنه يخلص 12 أو 10 آلاف خطوة، وين أسويها؟
صعب
بالضبط
يضطر أنه يروح مجمع، وللا ما أدري أيش يروح يسوي
ولا ألاقي ممشى ولا هذا
المفروض أن هذه مو وظيفتي أو مو من مهامي اليومية
أو مو شيء أحاتيه
المفروض جزء من تصميم حياتي
المفترض
فهنا...
لأنك تطالع إذا سافرت برة في أماكن من المدن برضو...
مو كل الأماكن برة صديقة للمشاة
بس أي مدينة صديقة المشاة
تدري أنك تخلص يمكن 15 ألف، وأنت ما حسيت فيها
ما تحس
15 ألف خطوة، كأنه عادي
وهل تحس أنها متعبة؟
أبدًا
بالضبط، فأنت تقول: الحركة تتعب الإنسان
ممكن لا العكس
فأنت تبغى تقول: أن المنظومة وطريقة الحياة اللي نعيشها هي خلتنا بهذا الشكل؟
نعم، لأن لما نفكر الحين بالحركة، نفكر بأني أنا قاعد أربعة وعشرين ساعة
وأروح أمشي ساعة، صح هذه الساعة راح تكون متعبة، طبيعي
لأن في شيء اسمه يسمى «مبدأ SAID»
أو التكيّف المحدد مع المتطلبات المفروضة
أن الجسم يتأقلم على الضغوطات أو المتطلبات بشكل يومي
الحين أنا وإيّاك نسجل بودكاست ثلاث ساعات
الجسم راح يقول: أنا راح أقعد هنا ثلاث ساعات
ولأن أمير وعبدالرحمن قاعدين ثلاث ساعات
راح أخلي الحركة أصعب عليه، والجلوس أسهل
فتتغير الوضعية، وأخذ الوضعية اللي أنا أقوم فيها أكثر، باليوم
وهذه بتسبب لي المشاكل؟
وللا ممكن الجسم يتعود على أن الجلسة شيء طبيعي
فيصبح المشي هو اللي يسبب لي المشاكل؟
إذا راح تكمل الجلسة طول حياتك ما راح تسبب لك مشاكل
بس هنا كله على طلبك في الحياة
مثلًا أنت إنسان رياضي، وتبي تجري
للجري في مؤهلات معينة
أن الورك والقدم لازم يتحركان بشكل سليم
بس إن أنت قاعد طول اليوم
اللي تسويه خلال اليوم، وتأقلم جسمك على هذه الوضعية
اللي هي الجلوس، راح تكون مختلفة جدًّا عن المتطلبات للركض
فهنا احنا ندش بمشاكل
أن أنت قاعد في ثني الورك أو فخدك قريب، أقرب لصدرك لفترة طويلة
وفي الركض، أحتاج أن فخدي يرجع وراي شوي مع كل خطوة أخذها
ما عندي هذه المتطلبات، وأنا أغصب جسمي على حركة معينة
هنا احنا ندخل في مشاكل
الجلوس يسبب مشاكل أكثر للإنسان، وللا الوقوف؟
أي حركة ثابتة راح تسبب مشاكل، الأساس التنوع في الحركة
فإذا أنا واقف فترة طويلة ممكن تسبب لي مشاكل بالظهر أو بالرقبة
نشوفها واجد عند أطباء الأسنان
فيكون واقف طول الوقت
يقول: يا أخي أنا ظهري ورقبتي ذبحتني، شوف لي حل
والحل أني أتنوع في الحركة، أغير وقوفي وجلوسي
أغير الوضعية اللي أنا فيها بين فترة وفترة
فأي ثبات هنا يعرّض الإنسان إلى آلام أو إصابات أكثر
الدكتور «فيصل سعود» كتب تغريدة أتوقع أنه كان يرد على...
في مقطع لـ«أحمد الشقيري»
فكان «أحمد الشقيري» يقول: أنه لازم الإنسان يجلس الجلسة الصحيحة أو الصحية
فكان جالس زي كذا، بس إذا دنّق رأسه، هون يصير...
حِمل
لأنك أنت لما تلعب أو تقعد على الجوال، تصير رقبتك مدنقة
فيصير في عندي ثلاثة عشر كيلو، ويضغط عليك
أو أيًّا يكن حجم دماغك
فكان رد «فيصل» أن ما في شيء اسمه الجلسة الصحية
أن أي جلسة هي جلسة صحية
أيّهما تميل إلى «أحمد» وللا «فيصل»؟
موضوع جدًّا، للمستمع العادي اللي ما له علاقة في المجال
ما يدري أن هذا الموضوع فيه جدل كبير جدًّا
أن هل وضعية الإنسان تأثر على وظيفته أو حركته، وللا لا؟
أميل للطرفين
أن بكل بساطة إذا قعدت في وضعية معينة لوقت طويل
راح أرسل إشارات لجسمي أنك حافظ على هذه الوضعية
فدائمًا يقول لك مثلًا أخصائيين العلاج الطبيعي أو الباحثين
بأن أنت لازم تغير الوضعية بين فترة وفترة
في منظور آخر، إذا قعدت في وضعية ثني الورك، مرة ثانية
خلنا نقول إذا هذا الكرسي أو أنا إنسان طويل
وضعية الفخذ راح تصير أقرب من الصدر في فترة أطول
وراح يصعب علي أني أغير وضعية الظهر
كلما ثنيت الركبة أعلى، كلما ظهري أصبح مسطح أكثر لفترة طويلة
فأنا راح أفرق عنك في كرسي منخفض أو واطي
ما راح أقدر أغير وضعيتي
أنا الآن وقاعد، صعب علي أقوم وأقعد
لأن ركبتي أعلى شوي من وضعية الفخذ
للحين الموضوع طازج، ما هو نهائي
اللي يقول لك: هذا جواب نهائي، ما هو كذلك
أيش اللي تنصح فيه؟
لأن أغلب الناس، حتى تلقى مثلًا الحين الأمهات، وللا أي...
لأن هذه المعلومة الدارجة، أنك إذا دنّقت هذا غلط، أنت لازم تجلس كذا
فرجّع ظهرك
هل أرجع ظهري، وللا أقدم، وللا عادي أسوي كل شيء؟
أقول لك: سوي كل شيء، لأنه يعطيك تنويع بالحركة، ليش؟
لأن نشوف في مشاكل عند اللي يرجعون رأسهم وراء، ويخلون ظهرهم سيدا
مثل فئتين: العسكريين ولاعبات أو لاعبي الباليه
دائمًا هذين عندهم أن الأكتاف لازم ترجع للوراء، ورأسي بهذا الشكل
مع الوقت نلاقي بأن أعلى الظهر صار بالعكس، متيبّس
وأنا لازم يكون عندي قابلية على أن الأكتاف ولوح الكتف
أنه يروح للأمام، ويرجع للوراء
إذا خليته بهذه الوضعية فترة طويلة، وغصبته على هذا الشيء
راح يأخذ هذه الوضعية أيضًا
فأنا أحتاج الاثنين مو بس وحدة، أحتاج التنوع
أحتاج أروح في نطاق حركي كبير
على أساس أخذ راحتي لما متطلبات الحياة تتطلب مني ذلك
مثلًا في النزول إذا كنت في العسكرية أو الباليه
نشوفهم دائمًا بأن أعلى الظهر حتى مع النزول، الركوع مثلًا
يكون جدًّا سيدا أو متصلب، حتى لما تقول له: رَخْ، ما يقدر يرخّي
وهذه إشكالية بحد ذاتها، لأنه ما أقدر أفعل عضلات معينة بجسمي
إذا ظهري ظل مستقيم طول الوقت
فأجاوب على سؤالك بأن الاثنين صحيحين
ولكن ما أتفق على أن الوضعية أو وضعية القوام
ما تأثر على الحركة، على المدى البعيد
بالنسبة للجلسات
أنت قبل شوي، قلت: أن الجلسة تفرق معك حتى على الكرسي
في عندك الحين، أنك جالس على الكرسي، وللا متربّع؟
متربّع، بس مو لهدف التربّع...
أيّهما صحي أكثر، تتربع أو جلسة طالب العلم، عرفتها؟
إي، راح أختار التربّع أكثر، لأنه راح يكون على الأغلب على الأرض
فعندي حرية بالحركة أكثر
راح يكون عندي قابلية أني أقوم في مدى حركي، وأقعد أكثر، صحيح؟
فراح أطلب أو راح يكون في متطلبات من الورك من أسفل الظهر، أعلى
فنشوف مثلًا في دراسات صارت على مقارنةً بين عضلات قاع الحوض
عند نساء آسيويات وغربيات، ما أذكر الدول الغربية يمكن مقارنةً بأمريكا
وشافوا بأن عضلات قاع الحوض فيها قوة ومرونة أكثر عند الآسيويات
لأنه ينزلون في وضعية القرفصاء أكثر من الجلوس على الكرسي
فراح أخذ جسمي في مدى حركية أكبر، وهذا دائمًا يكون شيء صحي
العجيب، ظنيتك بتقول: أنك لما تتربع بيكون مضر
لأن أيش اللي يصير، بس ممكن لأني أنا صحتي الحركية سيئة
بس يمكن لما تتربع، أتوقع تعطيني ساعة، وبعدها رجلي نمّلت
ظهري عوّرني، فتلقاني بدأت أحرّك
صح
بس لو أقعد على الكرسي عادي
هذا الشيء خاص فيك، صح؟
يمكن ما أعرف
إي، لأنه عند البدو عادي
اللي متعود على التربّع فترات طويلة، عادي يقوم
وتشوفه مثلًا يقعد، ويقوم يصب قهوة، ويستقبل ضيف
عادي يقوم من التربع إلى الوقفة
ما عنده هذه الفترة اللي مفاصله شوي شوي تتليّن
لا، أنا أتكلم إذا طولت شوي، فإذا قعدت ساعة
لأنك مو متعود، الورك عندك مو متعود، للأسباب اللي تكلمنا عنها
الحين أغلب الناس ما يرتاح بالتربع لفترة طويلة على الأرض
لأن وركه أو الفخذ عنده
ما قد قعد بهذه الوضعية اللي هي التربع لفترة طويلة
بس تشوف المتعودين على الأرض عادي عندهم
فشفت وثائقي قريب في نتفلكس عن المدن أو المناطق الزرقاء
اللي هي تكثر فيها المُعمّرين
وتشوفهم في مدن مثل: أوكيناوا في اليابان، وسردينيا في إيطاليا
ثلاث ساعات باليوم عندهم الزراعة، وهذا في اليابان
فتنزل وتصعد، ولا كأنه في شيء
لكن أنا وإيّاك لو نقعد ساعة، ما في مجال، بس هم متعودين
فالجسم، هذا الحلو، هذا الزين والشين بالجسم
أنه يتأقلم على اللي تعطيه
أعطيته جلوس راح يحبه، أعطيته حركة راح يحبها
هذه القاعدة الأساسية
كلما كثّرنا حركة من احنا وصغار لآخر يوم، إن شاء الله، بحياتنا
كلما كان الوضع أفضل
فبكل بساطة أنت مو متعود على التربّع، لذلك ما راح تلاقيه مريح
أصح للجسم أنك تأكل متربع، وللا على طاولة؟
ما عندي الجواب
ما عندك
ما...
في الطاولات الواقفة، تعرفها؟
إي
مفيدة للناس، وللا الوقفة مضرة برضو؟
أنا لازم أقول مفيدة، لأنه عندي وحدة
المفترض تقول كذا إذا كنت تملك شركة تبيع، إذا ما تبيع، ما تفرق معك
التنوع في الحركة، نعم، بسبب الطاولة راح يكون مفيد للإنسان
خاصةً أشوف أن قابليتي على خلق أفكار، وتفكير بعمق أكثر
يكون موجود لما أتحرك، أروح وأرجع، ويكون عندي طاولة أكتب عليها
فنعم
الآن إذا أنا جالس أسوي سلوك في جلستي مو بصحي
كيف أتعود؟
كيف ألقى المكان المناسب بالنسبة لي، اللي بخليني بصحة حركية أفضل؟
الموضوع عبدالرحمن، نفس إذا تحاول تتعود على سلوك جديد
في قاعدة في العلاج الحركي، وفي نفسها موجودة في العلاج السلوكي
اللي يسمونها التعرض متدرج
هو أنك أنت تعرض الشخص للسلوك الجديد شوي شوي
خلنا نأخذها على مثال نفسي، شخص عنده رُهاب من الأصنصير
أول شيء تسويه، تأخذه أنت كمعالج
تقول له: هذا الأصنصير تشوفه، خلك خمس دقائق، واقف بعيد عنه
ثاني يوم: قرّب، ثالث يوم: طق الدقمة
رابع يوم: شوف الباب يفتح ويسكر
خامس يوم: اركب واطلع
سادس يوم: أوقف وخلك شوي، بعدين اطلع
إلى ما يصير عنده عادي أنه يصعد وينزل
نفس الشيء بالنسبة للمفاصل
تأخذها شوي شوي إلى مداها الحركي الجديد
إذا كان التربع، شوي شوي أعوّد عضلات الضم على أنها تفتح
وتضل في هذه الوضعية، ومع الوقت راح تفتح معي
في تمارين خاصة علاجية أو تصحيحية، راح تساعد أكثر وأكثر
لأن الجسم دائمًا يكون في توازن ما بين العضلات الشادّة والمرتخية
على سبيل المثال، إذا صعب علي أتربع
راح تكون عندي مثلًا الركب مرتفعة
معناته ما عندي مرونة في عضلات الضامة الداخلية
إذا بساعد جسمي في هذه الناحية
لازم أقوّي العضلات العكسية اللي هي العضلات الخاطفة
لأنها هذه عضلات الضامة، عكسها الخاطفة
وهي عضلات الأرداف الخارجية
كلما قوّيت العضلات الخارجية للورك كلما صار عليه أسهل أنه يفتح
ففي نظام التعرض المتدرج أو أني أتعرض للمدى الحركي شوي شوي
بشكل تدريجي
نعم، هو أني أساعده عن طريق تدخيل عضلات أخرى
على أساس يفتح الحوض معي شوي شوي
فإذا بفهم الجلوس الحين، إذا بلخصه
بكون جلوسي صحي، ويساعدني في أنها تكون حركتي صحية
إذا أني جلست بأشكال مختلفة، أني ما أجلس على جلسة واحدة
مدة أكثر من ساعة
نعم
أني أغيرها، ولا يهم بالضبط أيش اللي أنا بجلس عليه
بالضبط
ممكن توقف وتتحرك، وتمشي عشر دقائق، ترجع لنفس الجلسة
وبكذا تكون أنت ما عندك مشاكل سببها الجلوس
نعم، وأيضًا الحين يصممون كراسي ملائمة لتنوع
أو طلب الجسم للتنوع مع الوقت
اللي هي تصير مثل منصة، ما هي كرسي عادي
منصة كأنها قطعة أرض بس مرتفعة
فأنت تقدر تتربع أو ترفع أو تنزل رجل وحدة
وعلى أثرها أنت تأقلم جسمك مع الوقت
لكنها شركة صغيرة، وتبيع نوع واحد
ولكن أشوف أن مع الوقت راح تتوسع، إلا ما تتوسع
عندك وحدة منها؟
لا والله، هذه طلبية، كان أول شيء على الطاولة بعدين الكرسي
إيوة الطاولة موجودة كثير، أتوقع حتى إيكيا تبيعها، متاحة بكثرة
فالطاولات أمرها بسيط، بس أحيانًا تنسى
عندنا هنا الطاولات كلها تطلع وتنزل
صح
بس ما أتذكر والله يمكن لي أسبوعين ما قد خليتها توقف
لأنك مشغول باللي تسويه، مو وقتها أرفع وأنزّل
أنسى، وأحيانًا ممكن أرفعها، وأقعد ساعة أو ساعتين، وأنا واقف وأنسى..
أنك تغير
أغير جلستي، فهي مشكلة
ممكن لازم تقلل ساعات العمل أكثر
ندخلك بالنشاط الرياضي أكثر، بس أدري فيك صعب عليك يمكن
لدرجة أن الرياضة، أنت على المنظومة، أن أصبحت الرياضة رفاهية
نعم
أنت تدفع فلوس في نادي عشان تروح تتحرك، أنت متخيل؟
نعم، أنا وإيّاك مولودين في جيل النادي عادي
صح
في عالِم اسمه «موشي فيلدينكرايس»
هذا فيزيائي ومهندس ميكانيكي
دش في هذا العالم عن طريق ركبته، كان عنده مشكلة بركبته
قال الدكتور شوف، أنا أتكلم يمكن بالـ 1930 أو 1940
قال له: موضوعك عملية، قال له: لو شنو ما أسوي عملية
أنا بعالج نفسي بنفسي، وعالج نفسه، وأسس مدرسة
فلما جابوه أمريكا، شاف في ناس عند بار العقلة، يتمرنون
فسأل اللي معه، قال له: أيش يسوون؟ قال: هذول يتمرنون
قال: ليش، ما في حركة بشكل يومي، خلال اليوم ما يكتفون من الحركة؟
فكان المفهوم جديد وغريب عليهم
نفس ما طلعت الحين النوادي أول ما طلعت، كان معروف بالسويدي
كان شيء غريب مو مقبول، ومع الوقت لحاجتنا، وإدراكنا لأهميتها
صار جزء من الطبيعة
بالنسبة للركبة، أنت جبت طاري الركبة
هذه واحدة من المشاكل اللي تصير الناس، حتى الرياضيين
من أكثر الإصابات اللي يتعرض لها الرياضي
وبالنسبة للناس العاديين، خصوصًا كبار السن
من الأشياء اللي تصير لهم الركبة
ما هي بعضلة أمرنها، شلون أمرن ركبتي؟
صح الركبة، أغلب حالات الركبة المشكلة مو منها نفسها
الفكرة بالجسم، عبدالرحمن، نفس عندك شركة فيها خمسة أعضاء
واحد من هذه الأعضاء عليه كل الضغط
وكل الشغل والمواعيد عليه، بالنهاية راح يتعب
ممكن تعطيه إجازة، يطلع أسبوعين أو ثلاثة، ويرجع متجدّد
بس لما يرجع لبيئة العمل، راح يرجع يتعب
فأيش الأفضل أنك تسوي؟ أنك توزع المهام على الأربعة الباقيين
نفس الشيء بالجسم، الركبة مفصل طايح بين الورك والقدم
وأغلب مشاكل الركبة بأن ما في اتصال صحيح بين الورك والقدم
فلما شخصي يجيني عنده مشكلة ركبة مزمنة
ما أطالع الركبة أبدًا، لأنها ضحية، هي اللي تصارخ
إذا كان عندك طفل يبكي تدوّر مِن طقه
ما تروح تقول: أيش فيك واسكت، فنفس الفكرة
تروح تشوف الورك، شو اللي ما يسويه؟
تشوف القدم، هل تتسطح وتتقوس بشكل سليم؟
وعلى أساسه أعالج الركبة، وأغلب مشاكلها جذي أعالجها
أيش اللي يسبب ألم الركبة؟
أيش العادات اللي الناس تسويها، تسبب هذا؟
خلنا نأخذها أول شيء من ناحية علمية
المدى الحركي في الورك اللي هو الدوران الداخلي
فالدوران الداخلي هو لما تشوف يمكن أطفال خاصةً البنات
يقعدون في وضعية الـ(W) وهي الركبة تدخل إلى الداخل، والقدم تطلع لبرة
هذا المدى الحركي مطلوب من جسم الإنسان إلى حد ما
أغلب الناس أشوف أن هذا المدى الحركي عندهم قليل
فعلى أثرها يصير الضغط أكثر على الركبة
من ناحية أخرى، القدم، خاصةً عندنا في الخليج
تلاقي في عنا تسطّح أعلى بالقدم، القدم المسطحة أكثر
عكس أوربا، في تقوّس أعلى
لكن الاثينن إذا ما كان في ديناميكية في الحركة
راح تلاقي أن الركبة هي اللي تأخذ الحمل أكثر
فالعادات السليمة أو الشيء تلقائي أسويه
على أساس أحسّن من تقوس وتسطّح القدم، وأخلّي الورك مرن وقوي
أني أمارس رياضات فيها دوران، كل الرياضات فيها دوران
كرة القدم فيها دوران
دوران عبارة عن أن القفص الصدري يروح لجهة، والحوض يروح لجهة
الحين لما تفكر فيها، لما أنت تمشي
إذا أخذت خطوة برجلك اليمين، أي يد تروح للأمام؟
اليسار
نفس الشيء بكرة القدم، لما اللاعب يشوط برجله اليمين، يده اليسار تروح للأمام
هذا عبارة عن دوران
فكلما مارست أنا رياضات فيها دوران أكثر
اللي هي كرة سلة والقدم، كل الرياضات تقريبًا فيها دوران
تأثر على الركبة؟
لا، راح تحسن من الركبة
أنت تعطي الركبة أو الورك مدى حركي أكبر
عشان تخفف الحمل عن الركبة نفسها
هنا في عوامل أخرى
لأن تقول: أمير هَم الرياضات تسبب مشاكل بالركبة
كل شخص عن شخص راح يختلف في مداه الحركي في الورك
شنو يسوي طول حياته؟ هل عنده إصابات سابقة بالكاحل؟
راح تأثر على الورك، وعلى أثرها تأثر على الركبة، في عوامل واجد مختلفة
الإنسان العادي خلنا نقول: يبلش من عمر ستة عشر وثمانية عشر
وحتى قبل أربعة عشر، يمارس رياضات فيها دوران، راح تساعد هذا الشيء
فإذا قدمك مسطحة، على الأرجح أن ركبتك تكون يجيها آلام ركبة؟
مو على الأرجح، كله يعتمد...
هي سالفة الألم أو الإصابة، هذه الإشكالية
أن ما نقدر نقول: هذا الهيكل راح يسبب هذا الألم
لأن الموضوع مثل طبقات اللازانيا
شو المجهود اللي تحط عليه؟
الأحذية وعمرك الرياضي، وإصابات سابقة وللا لا
أيش تقصد بعمرك الرياضي؟
هل أنت تمارس الرياضة صار لك عشر، وللا توّه بدأت؟
إصابات سابقة، وعندك مشاكل في الكاحل، وللا لا؟
كلها تعطينا تجربة الألم
ما أقول: أن شخص عنده قدم مسطحة أو قابلة أكثر للتسطح
معناته عنده ألم ركبة
في حالات نشوف فيها أن القدم المسطحة، بالعكس تعطيني أفضلية
مثل لو تشوف «يوسين بولت» قدمه شوي...
اللي هو أسرع شخص في العالم
عنده قدم شوي تميل إلى التسطح، مو مسطحة 100%
وهنا في فرق بين التسطح الهيكلي والوظيفي
في عنده نزول شوية بالتسطح، وأموره طيبة
نفس الشي مع «ليبرون جيمس»
اللي هو من أفضل لاعبي كرة السلة في العالم
عنده شوية تسطّح في القدم
وأيش مشكلة القدم المسطحة؟
بحد ذاتها ما هي مشكلة
بس القدم تمر في دورة اسمها دورة المشي
الحين عندك الآيفون في الـ«آي أو إس»
ومثلًا الكمبيوتر فيه البرمجة ماله، فيه النظام اللي يشغله
اللي يشغل جسم الإنسان هي دورة المشي
اللي هي أنا أول ما أخذ خطوة تكون على الكعب
بعدين على منتصف القدم بعدين على المشط، هذه البرمجة
ما عندك شخص بالعالم راح يكون فيه خلل، إذا مشى على أمشاط قدمه
وهذا نشوفه مشكلة عند الأطفال تُعالج
كلنا نبلش احنا في المشي مع الكعب أول شي، هذا الطبيعي
لما قدمي تحوش الأرض، وهي على الكعب
القدم تكون في وضعية التقوس
أول ما الوزن يصير فوق الرجل كاملة، القدم تبلش تتسطح
ومع الدفع في آخر مرحلة، ترجع تتقوس
فأحتاج أن القدم تتسطح وتتقوس في دورة المشي
أو مع كل خطوة أخذها، وحتى مع الرياضات
فإذا كان عندي قدم مسطحة ما تتقوس هنا مشكلة
وإذا كان عندي قدم مقوّسة ما تتسطح، هنا مشكلة
لأني أحتاجهم لصحة القدم نفسها، وصحة الركبة والورك
كيف أعرف إذا رجلي مسطحة، وللا لا؟
وخصوصًا إذا ما كانت مسطحة بشكل...
100% في الحين عندنا...
أشوفها معك
لا، مو مسطحة
تمام؟
إي، ممكن نحسّن التقوس اللي فيها مع تمارين، بس فيها تقوس
في بعض الناس...
اللي هو التقوس الصحي يعتبر؟
التقوس صحي، لازم القدم تكون في وضعية عادية، فيها شوية تقوس
في نوعين من الناس
خلنا نقول إذا أنت كنت شوية أنزل من جذي
يصير عندك ألم في القدم، على طول الناس تروح عند دكتور مثلًا
يحولهم إلى تصميم أحذية
اللي هي ألمانية، واللي تكون مخصصة فعلًا لقدمك
ويقولون: لا، لازم نحط قطعة، على أساس نقوس القدم أكثر
إذا أنت قوست القدم أكثر، وحطيت قطعة تمنعها من التسطح
خلقت مشكلة جديدة
اللي هي القدم ما تقدر تتسطح، فأنا منعتها من التسطح
لازم يكون عندي الحركة الديناميكية في المجالين
فإذا أبي أحسن من تقوس قدمي، في تمرين تصحيحية لهذا الشيء
ونفس فكرة الورك مع الركبة، تمارين فيها دوران
كيف أعرف أنها صحيّة، وللا لا؟
الحين إذا بنختصر موضوع القدم، راح أختصره بشغلتين
الحين المستمع أو المشاهد ممكن يسويها
إذا وقفت، عادي وقفتك العادية
وحطيت يديك على أكتافك، ودرت كامل جسمك، وطالعت وراءك
القدم اليمين، إذا أنت درت لليمين، المفروض أنها تتقوس
يصير فيها تقوس أعلى
نقدر نفحص هذا الشيء أنا وإيّاك بعدين
وفي نفس الوقت، وهي تتقوس، لازم يكون في ثلاث نقاط ضغط متوزعة
ما بين أساس الإصبع الكبير، الإبهام
ما بين الإصبع الصغير، والكعب
هؤلاء الثلاث نقاط لازم يكونون على الأرض
هنا أسميه أنا تقوس سليم، حلو
إذا أحد من هذه النقاط ارتفع
في هذه الحالة عادةً أشوف واجد الصبع الكبير يرتفع
معناته التقوس غير كامل
في تقوس بالقدم، ولكنه غير كامل
لأن أحتاج هذه النقاط تكون على الأرض
على أساس أشكل شكل الهرم، اللي هو قوي للقدم نفسها
هذا فحص بسيط، في فحوصات أقوى وأدق
تبين لي ارتفاع العظمة السفينية، شكلها نفس السفينة، عن الأرض
وأشوف تطورها مع الوقت
وعادةً اللي عنده مثلًا هذه، وييبغى يفحصها، وين يروح؟
أخصائي علاج طبيعي
هنا الإشكال أن عادةً واجد من أخصائي العلاج الطبيعي
في ناس واجد ملمّة بالموضوع، وفي ناس لا
أول ما تشوف الهيكل مسطح، يقول: عندك قدم مسطحة
روح فصل لك قطعة داخل الحذاء، أو أن دير بالك مع الوقت راح تتألم
وهذا الشيء غير صحيح
لازم أشوف أنا حركة القدم مو بس هيكلها، عشان أحكم على وظيفتها
وأنت قلت: أن في تسطح وظيفي وهيكلي
نعم
أيش الفرق؟
بمعنى أن الحين أنت نفس ما قلت لي: القدم لازم يكون فيها تقوس
نوع من أنواع التقوس، ما راح أقول حاد، فيها تقوس
فيها فراغ ما بين الجزء الداخلي من القدم والأرض، هذا الطبيعي
في واجد ناس عندهم لا
العظمة السفينية هذه اللي تكلمت عنها، ملامسة للأرض
هذا يكون هيكليًّا هو ملامس للأرض
نحسّن من وظيفتها، ولكن هيكلها ما راح يتغير
راح يكون عندها قابلية شوية على التقوس لما أحتاجها
ولكن طول الوقت راح تكون هي مسطحة
يمكن شوية ترتفع مع الوقت، بس مو ذاك الارتفاع
القدم المسطحة خلنا نقول الوظيفية
هي مثل «ليبرون جيمس» و«يوسين بولت»
القدم صايرة متسطحة أكثر شوية، ولكن عندها قابلية على التقوس
الفئة الأولى ما عندها قابلية على التقوس
أبدًا؟
إي في ناس، أنا واحد منهم، لأن قدمي مسح على الأرض
ولذلك أنا تعمقت أكثر في موضوع القدم، لي أنا قبلما يكون لغيري
شلون حليتها؟
ما حليتها، اللي سويته أن قويت القدم أكثر
لأنه هي، أنا مو ناطر أن قدمي تتقوس
ولكن أبيها شوي تعطيني، مو ناطرها تتقوس وهي ثابتة
بس أبيها تتقوس شوي لما أعطيها حركة التقوس
تقويات بشكل يومي، يا عبدالرحمن
الناس اللي عندها قدم مسطحة
عادةً عبالها الموضوع أسبوع أو شهر أو شهرين، وأخلص
أنا اليوم الصبح راكض، هنا عندكم وادي حنيفة
وقبلها عشر دقايق أو ربع ساعة لازم أشتغل على قدمي
والحي أركض أربعة وعشرين أو خمسة وعشرين كيلو من غير ألم
فأدري أن هذه نقطة الضعف عندي، ولازم أشتغل عليها مدى الحياة
ما لها علاج؟
في عمليات، بس نفس الفكرة ترجع
إذا أعطيت تقوس للقدم عن طريق براغي، وتغيير هيكلي للعظام
منعت القدم من التسطح
في واجد ناس يسوون العملية، وللحين في ألم
لأن الأنسجة للحين متعودة على الوضعية القديمة، فهمت علي
لازم أعود أنا الساق
شنو وضع الساق والورك عندك بعد العملية؟
ففي منظومة معقدة اللي هي يسمونها (Complex System)
ما أقدر أغير شيء واحد، وأتوقع أن كل شيء ثاني راح يظل سليم
لازم الأشياء الثانية تتأثر، لأنها كلها مرتبطة ببعض
هل في «علامة تجارية» معينة جيدة، للي عندهم رجل مسطحة؟
مؤهلات الحذاء اللي أشوفه وظيفي للكل
هو أول شيء أن يكون، نفس ما تكلمنا في البداية
أن مساحة الأصابع لازم تكون عريضة
لأن القدم طبيعتها عريضة من الأمام، وأضعف من الوراء، هذه كل قدم
لازم الحذاء يكون فيه شوية مرونة
بعدين نرجع إلى موضوع التسطح أو التقوس
بأنه يكون شوي مدعوم من الداخل
إذا أبي أمارس رياضة شدتها عالية، بركض على فترات طويلة
فتلاقيني الحين لابس هذا أنا، ما فيه أي دعم
لأنك ما تمارس رياضة
لأن ما أحتاج، أبي قدمي تعتمد على نفسها
ولكن إذا بركض خمسة وعشرين أو ستة وعشرين كيلو
هنا أحتاج شوية دعم
لأن في النهاية القوة أو كثر ما أمرن قدمي راح يكون لها حد معين
أحتاج شيء خارجي يدعمها
فالعلامات التجارية، أنت سألت عنها
اللي أفضله أنا للقدم المسطحة والجهد العالي
«بروكس» علامة تجارية أمريكية، النوع المعين«أدرينالين» ممتاز
اللي دارج أكثر اللي هو «إيسكس كيانو» (ASICS KAYANO)
بس أنا يناسبني الـ«بروكس» أكثر
للاستخدام اليومي اللي فيه شوية دعم أو بطانة من تحت، مو دعم
ولكن يعطيك حاجز بينك وبين الأرض «الألترا» ممتاز
«ألترا أديداس»؟
لا، «ألترا رانينق»
«ألترا أديداس» يمكن «يو إل تي آر إيه»
«الألترا رانينق» شركة أمريكية أو كندية على ما أظن «إيه إل تي آر إيه»
مخصصة للركض، ولكن عندهم أحذية يومية
والشخص اللي يبي كأنه حافي «فيفو» ممتاز
ليش مثلًا أتذكر العسكرية، يرفضونك
إذا رجلك، أو يفحصون، رجلك مسطحة، لا تجي انتهى الموضوع
أيش العلاقة؟
يمكن أنها مبنية على معتقد قديم، نعم
لأن أشوف واجد في ناس عندهم قدم مسطحة، وعادي
فممكن أني أنا أغير هذا الفحص
أيش كان المعتقد القديم؟
أن قدمه ضعيفة، مع الوقت راح يتعب في البوت
ونشوف في ناس صحيح يتعبون، وفي ناس لا
فالأفضل أني أقيّم حركته، أنا الحين عندي شخص جاي قدمه مسطحة
أنتِ شنو تحتاجين مني، يا عسكرية؟
أني أقفز مثلًا، خلنا نقول ثلاث دقايق متواصلة من غير ألم؟
اختبرني في هذه، اختبر الوظيفة نفسها
تبي تختبر قوتي؟ الحين في أجهزة تختبر القوة
قدمك ضعيفة؟ حسنًا، هالكثر نيوتن، أو ما تقدر تطلع هذه القوة؟
لا، ما راح نقبلك
نفس ما هم يفحصون الرفع والسحب والركض
افحص وظيفة القدم، حط لي قاعدة أنط عليها، وشوف أيش كثر أنا أطلع قوة
وخلني أنط من جهة لجهة
لأن هذا راح يكون صعب على اللي عنده قدم مسطحة
وشوفني هل عندي مشكلة وللا لا، وعلى هذا الأساس خذني
فالمعايير قديمة
الجري، أحس أن في ناس كثير تفتي، فما تصير تدري
فمثلًا كثير يقولون: أنت لازم تجري أنك تنزل قدمك على المشط
لأن هذا صحي، ويخليك تجري بانسيابية، ومدري أيش
نعم
وفي مقطع ثاني برضو، وكلها هذه الروابط بنحطها في النشرة
في مقطع ثاني يقول: أنه ما يفرق طالما أنك تلبس جزمة رياضية
فكل المساعدات اللي أنت، صحيح لو أنك حافي تنزل على مشطك، أفضل
بس إذا أنت تلبس جزمة رياضية ففيها مساعدات اللي ما عاد تفرق
تنزل على كاحلك أو لا
أثرها ما يفرق، فما عاد تفرق كيف تجري
فهل في فرق في الجري والركض؟
وفي معلومة مميزة أنت قلتها
أن القدم تلقائيًّا تنزل على المشط لما تكون حافي
كنوع من أنواع الدعم
بس إذا شفت أنت العدائين العالميين
راح تلاقي الكينيين وغيره في اختلاف
في اختلاف ما بين النزول على مو الكعب
نقول: منتصف القدم وبين المشط أكثر
الحين احنا كلنا نحاتي من ناحية إصابة
أنا بركض بالشكل السليم
لأن بعد خمسين أو ستين كيلو في الأسبوع أركضه
أبي أرجع أركض، ما أبي أتعور
فالأبحاث تبين بأن إذا نزلت على المشط
عُرضة وتر الاكيليس، العرقوب من الوراء للإصابة أعلى
وإذا نزلت على الكعب، عُرضة الركبة للإصابة أعلى
فأنت الحين بين نارين
أنت اختار
أنت اختار، وأنت وجسمك
دائمًا نلاقي بأن وحدة من الشغلات المهمة
هي مو بس القدم نازل على الكعب وللا المشط، مكان النزول
أن لا يكون أنك تأخذ خطوة أكبر منك، بحيث أن قدمك تصير أمامك
فكأنك أنت تدوس توقف مع كل خطوة تأخذها
تبي القدم تكون نسبيًّا تحتك، يمكن شوية مقدمة، إذا أنت سرعات عالية
بس تبيها نسبيًّا قريبة منك مو بعيدة
فالميكانيكا الحيوية للركض معقد، مو بس القدم
وفي عنصر الركبة والعمل
في عالِم هولندي حط أسس لهذا الموضوع
بأن أنت لما تأخذ الخطوة خاصةً بالركض لمسافات قصيرة
أن لازم الحركة تبدأ من الورك مو من القدم
شلون؟
تخيل أنك قبل لا قدمك تلامس الأرض، أنت تسحب سحب من الورك
ففي عامل السحب، جاي من الفخذ الخلفي والأرداف
راح يساعد القدم مع الالتماس
وحدة من العناصر الأخرى أن ظهرك يكون نوعًا ما سيدا
وفيه شوية لين أو انحناء للأمام، نعم
فأكثر من عامل، نفس ما قلنا مرة ثانية، موضوع له طبقات وعدة جوانب
بس الأساس من ناحية الأبحاث، وهذا صحي أو صحيح بالميكانيكا الحيوية
بأن لما تنزل على المشط، تعرّض البطات لضغط أعلى
فعرضة وتر الاكيليس للإصابة أعلى
ولما تنزل على الكعب تعرّض الركبة لضغوطات أعلى
فعرضة الإصابة للركبة أعلى
وأنت أيّهما تختار؟
مع سرعات أعلى، شيء ما أحد يختلف عليه
بأن في سباق مثل 100 متر، على المشط
ما في كعب، ما أحد ينزل على الكعب، تشوفهم كلهم
ولا واحد ينزل على الكعب تلقائي
لأن أنا أبي أطلع أكبر قوة في أقل مسافة
فطبيعي، كأني أركض على أصابعي أصير
بس أغلب الناس تجري، جري الماراثونات
أنا في هذه السرعات أنزل أقرب للأمام
ولكن على منتصف القدم أكثر من الكعب
التنفس بندخل له لحاله
نعم
ما مدى أهمية، في ناس تقول لك
أنك لما تجري لازم توزن التنفس معاها
فيقول لك: الظاهر كذا
صح؟
ما أعرف، وللا ما يفرق، أنت تتنفس، وجسمك بيعرف كيف تتنفس
وعلى الله الحال
من هذه الناحية، هذا مو من ضمن تخصصي، بس عن تجربة
مو تخصصك؟
لا، هذا يصير أكثر علم الرياضة، والناس المتخصصة أكثر في الركض
علوم الرياضة نفسها
أنا لي علاقة أكثر بالميكانيكا الحيوية
بس عن تجربة شخصية، صح لما تنظم
تحس أن صار في ربط ما بين القدم والنفس
في أسلوب، هذا أنا ابتدعته مع نفسي
بس مع المجهود العالي، أبلشه أعد عدد كم مرة أتنفس في الدقيقة
إلى ما أنسى، لأني تعبان
مثلًا مع كل خطوة أقول: واحد واثنين وثلاثة، لقيت نفسي نسيت
أعيد العد من الأول، وأشوف أني أقدر أطول أكثر
نعم، صح كلامك
أنفك، وللا فمك؟
أنفي، في المجهود المتوسط
فمي، آخر ركضة لما يكون المجهود عالي، ودقات قلبي وصلت 175-180
لا خلاص أنا أبي الطاقة الإنتاجية القصوى، وأقوى ما عندي
أستخدم الفم
بس في الطبيعي لا الأنف، وهذا الشي أنت تمرنه مع الوقت
ليش البطّات دائمًا تكون فيها المشكلة، فتنشد عند أغلب الناس؟
هو ما تنشد عند أغلب الناس، ممكن تكون مثلًا الفخذ الخلفي
بالفخذ أكثر؟
جاي بقول لك: أنها أكثر من الفخذ حتى عند الرياضيين، وللا؟
لا، نشوف إصابات...
في تساوي ما بين إصابات مثلًا الأخيل أو البطّات، والفخذ الخلفي
فنشوف في توزيع بينهم أكثر كإصابات
بس ممكن أن البطات ما تكون جاهزة من ناحية قوة أو من مرونة
واحدة من الشغلات اللي، خلنا نأخذها شوي من منظور
التعمير، أنك أنت تعيش لـ100 سنة
في هذه المجموعة اللي تكلمت عنها في سردينيا
شافوا أن في علاقة ما بين ارتفاع المكان اللي عايش فيه، وطول عمرك
أكسجين، وللا أيش؟
مو أكسجين، أنت تصعد مرتفعات
الحين أحد أهم العوامل أن الشخص يفقد صحته وتتدهور أكثر
هو السقوط، شيء أنا وإيّاك يمكن ما نفكر فيه حاليًا
بس عند اللي عمره سبعين أو خمسة وسبعين أو ثمانين
يخاف أنه يطيح
الحين أيش اللي يخليني أقل عرضة للسقوط؟
قوة البطات والأصابع، الأصابع نفسها
لما أقوي، أمس قرأت بحث عن هذا الموضوع
لما أقوّي أصابعي في وضعية إطالة
لما تكون هي ممتدة، هذه وضعية الإطالة
لما أقويها في هذه الوضعية، أنا الحين هنا وشديت على أصابع قدمي
راح أقويها أكثر بواجد
متى قدمي تكون في هذه الوضعية؟ مع المرتفعات
فاللي عايش في سردينيا أو هذه المناطق
يصعد وقلبه يستفيد، ولكن أيضًا قدمه والكاحل يستفيد
وعلى أثرها عرضته للسقوط تكون أقل
لأن السقوط هو أحد أهم الأسباب، أكثر أسباب الوفاة لكبار السن
نعم، فالكاحل يكون عنده فيه مدى حركة كافي
البطات تكون قوية، لأنه هو على مرتفع
والأصابع تكون قوية، هي أحد أهم عوامل في التوازن
فنشوف الناس كلما قلّت حركتها في الكاحل كلما صارت البطات أضعف
وكلما صارت عرضة أعلى للشد فيها
إذا كان عندي رجل أقصر من الأخرى، كيف ممكن أتعامل معها؟
الحين في فعلًا أحيانًا يكون عندنا رجل أطول من رجل
ولكن في أغلب الحالات يكون في عدم اتزان في الحوض نفسه
فلو تأخذ الحوض، وتمد الرجلين من تحته
إذا كان الحوض متساوي، راح يكون شكليًّا الأرجل نفس الطول
إذا ملت بالحوض شوي، خلنا نقول: ملت إلى جهة اليمين
راح يبين بأن الرجل اليمين أطول
ولكن هي المشكلة في الحوض نفسه
في الحالتين، إذا كان فعلًا عندي رجل أطول من رجل
أو عندي عدم اتزان في الحوض، أوازن الحوض؟
شلون أوازن الحوض؟
عن طريق موازنة عضلات الأرداف اليُمنى مع الضامة اليسرى، والعكس صحيح
فدائمًا في علاقة ما بين الجزء الخارجي مع الداخلي من الجسم في الجانب الآخر
فأوازنهم
وفي تمارين لهذا الموضوع
ومع الوقت تلاقي أن الحوض صار سيدا، والرجلين صاروا نفس الطول
إذا كان الموضوع مو فعلًا اختلاف بالطول
ولو في اختلاف بالطول؟
نفس المفهوم، لأن الحين ما تقدر تغير الهيكل
إلا في عمليات
إذا ما تبي عمليات، تقدر تقوي، نفس ما قلت
الجزء الخارجي من الورك مع الداخلي، وتوازنهم
ممتاز، بالنسبة للأندية الرياضية
أيش أكثر الأشياء اللي يقع الناس فيها
وتسبب لهم مشاكل في حركتهم، وصحتهم الحركية؟
هذا أنا أو أنت طحنا فيها، واجد ناس طاحوا فيها
التسرّع، مستعجل أبي أعضّل بشهر أو شهرين أو ثلاث، ما تصير
مفاصلك مو جاهزة، فالتدرج أهم عناصر التقدم في النادي
لازم يكون عندي تدرج محسوب
والحين، الحمد لله، صار في وعي بهذا الشيء مع المدربين والأخصائيين
أن أنت لازم تتدرّج حبة حبة، والعب على عشر سنين، لا تلعب على سنة
هذا أحسن شيء
ونفس الشيء يطيحون فيه مثلًا اللي يركضون
مثلًا أنا هذا الأسبوع، الحِمل مالي ثلاثين كيلو
أو خلنا نقول: أول ما ببلشت عشرة كيلو، الأسبوع اللي بعده أزيده حبة
الشهر اللي بعده أزيده حبة، فالتدرج، هذا هو أهم عنصر
العنصر الثاني أنك أنت لا تغصب نفسك على حركة مؤلمة
لا، روح شوف، شو المشكلة؟
عند أخصائي أو مدرب
الحين في مدربين فاهمين ممكن يعرفونك، أن أنت طريقتك غلط
أو الكتف ما فيه مدى حركي كافي
فخلنا نشتغل على المدى الحركي، بعدين نكمّل
النقطة الثالثة عدم الإحماء، يدخل على طول مباشرة
مهم جدًّا؟
إي عند الصغار عادي
أنت تذكر يمكن لما تلعب كرة، ما نسخن
صح
ندخل على طول، ماكو مشكلة
بس مع الوقت تحتاجها، تحتاج تجهز نفسك من ناحية دقات قلب
ومن ناحية المفاصل وحرارة الجسم بعدين تدخل
فهذه ممكن قد تكون أكثر عوامل تؤدي إلى الإصابة أو الألم
أو شخص يجيب العيد في نفسه
أنك ترفع وزن أثقل من قدرتك
هل يساعد العضلات على أنها تكون أفضل، وللا ممكن يسيء لجسمك؟
أكثر من قدرتك من أي ناحية؟
إذا قلنا: ما تقدر تشيله ومفاجئ، رفعة وحدة، هنا مضر
بس إذا كان شيء مدروس، بالعكس صحي جدًّا
هو نفس موضوع، نرجع إلى النفسية
إذا تبي تطلع خارج نقطة الراحة عندك، لازم تدرّج فيها
ما يصير أنا إنسان انطوائي، أروح حفلة فجأة، ما ينفع
لازم أتدرج شوي شوي، ومع التدرج راح يصير في قبول وتطور
أنت ما تقدر تستضيف مثلًا
إذا أنت أول أسبوع ضيف، ما تقدر ثاني أسبوع تستضيف ثلاثة أو أربعة
مُنهك تصير، نفس الفكرة بالضبط
فإذا كان الشيء مدروس، ما في مشكلة في الرفع
فإذا كان مدروس ومخطط له، يكون بالعكس سليم
تخصيص عضلات محددة للتمرين، إيجابية وللا سلبية؟
فتلقى الناس، «الباي» و«التراي» وهكذا
إذا بنأخذها، دائمًا أحب أنا أخذ الموضوع لآخر يوم بحياتك
الهدف بأن جسمك يكون شايل نفسه للشيخوخة
فلازم يكون في ترابط قوي ما بين العضلات
اللي يصير في كمال الأجسام، أني أفصل العضلة فصل
وأخصص هذا التمرين وهذا التمرين وهذا التمرين، لعضلات مختلفة
فصل العضلات لحالها، لا يعني ارتباطها في التمارين أو الحركات المركبة
لازم أدخّل تمارين تربطهم
فعلى سبيل المثال، إذا أنا أتعلم لغة
وأتدرب كل يوم أقول: تاء، وبكرة ميم، ما راح أقول: تميس
لا، قلت: تاء وميم
فإذا تدربت على تَم، تمي، تميس، هنا يصير في سلاسة في الحركة
نفس الفكرة، إذا أفعل «الباي» يتفعل بروحه
لازم يكون في حركات مركبة، خاصةً للرياضيين
ما يمنع أني أخصص تمارين معينة لعضلات معينة، لأنها ضعيفة عندي
بعدين أشبكهم مع بعض
بس لازم الربط يكون موجود في الجسم، لأن الجسم...
احنا اللي شرّحنا الجسم
وقلنا: هذا «الباي» وهذا الكتف
الجسم ما يدري، ما عنده أي فكرة أن هذا اسمه «الباي»
وهذا الكتف، يشتغل مع بعض
تبي ترفع إيدك راح أرفعها، أي عضلات مالي شغل راح نرفعها
فهذا أساس الجسم، احنا اللي جينا وشرحناه
فالحين نشوف في توجه أكثر إلى ربط
من خلال مدارس «أناتومي ترينز» ومدارس مختلفة
تشريحيًّا في ربط، هذا مثبت علميًّا
ما بين العضلات الخلفية للجسم كلها
من فروة الرأس إلى أخمص القدمين
قاع القدم عندك مشبوك في البطات والفخذ الخلفي
ومشبوك بأسفل الظهر ونص الظهر للفروة من فوق
من ناحية أخرى، في عندنا خط ثاني، هذا بعد مثبت علميًّا
ما بين عضلة الصدر وعضلات الخواصر مع عضلة الضامة
وهذا الشيء اللي يعطينا القدرة على المشي بالطريقة اللي نمشي فيها
فكلما عزلت، وتشوفها روح أي نادي الحين فيه مدربين كمال أجسام
وشوف مشيتهم، سيئة جدًّا، ما فيها كفاءة وترابط
الحين احنا نصمم العالم كله
على أن نأخذ أقل عدد من الطاقة لإنتاج أكبر حركة أو سرعة أو أي شيء
إلا في كمال الأجسام، ليش؟
أنت الحين مع المشي عند كمال الأجسام
حط له كالوري ميتر، احسب السعرات اللي يحرقها
راح تلاقيه يحرق أكثر من الشخص العادي
لأن ما في ترابط بالحركة، وفي جهد على عضلاته ومفاصله
بدل لا يكون فيها ترابط، وتشوفها بعينك
عجيب، أول مرة أنتبه للفكرة في هذا الشكل
أنت تقول: أن الإنسان المفترض أنه ما يسوي إطالة، ليه؟
دائمًا نأخذ أن الإطالة شيء مهم
ممكن أغير رأيي شوي شوي عن هذه الفكرة
ممتاز
نعم، الإنسان الثابت على رأيه ما هو إنسان متغير
ولا هو يواكب الواقع اللي يعيشه
للحين أنا على هذه الفكرة
البقرة الوحيدة اللي بتغير رأيها
أي شيء للحد الأقصى وشديد راح يكون مضر
فالإطالات الثابتة مثلًا نشوفها، مابي يزعلون مني، ولكن في اليوقا
أعرف واجد مدربين ومدربات يوقا
بس لما تأخذ عضلة، وتمغطها زيادة عن اللزوم، وتقعد فترة طويلة
وما أعطيتها العكس، ما عادت عضلة
العضلة هي نفس الربّاط المطاطي عندنا، ينمغط
ولازم مرة ثانية ينقبض، يطول ويقصر
إذا أنا عوّدته فقط على الطول
راح يفقد قابليته على الانقباض، إذا ما مرّنت الانقباض
فهذه إشكاليتي مع الإطالات الثابتة لفترة طويلة
ومن الجانب الآخر، هي مفيدة للجسم ومهمة للإنسان؟
سؤال صعب، أنا أميل إلى أن تكون الإطالة حركية
أيش تقصد؟
تأخذ المفصل إلى مداه الحركي اللي قادر عليه، ويكون في تحكم فيه
على سبيل المثال
شنو الفرق بين الإطالات الثابتة والحركية؟
الإطالات الثابتة أني أجيب جسم خارجي أو شيء خارجي أو إنسان ثاني
ويمغطني لفوق
الإطالات الحركية أني أنا أخذ المدى الحركي نفسه
وأتم في آخر المدى الحركي هذا، وأثبت في هذه الوضعية
ومع الوقت، أزيده
ففي مدرسة اسمها الـ«إف آر سي» تكييف المدى الوظيفي
يتّبعون هذا النظام، أني أنا أصل لمدى حركي كامل أو اللي عندي إياه
أثبت هنا، وأحاول مع الوقت أزيده، فراح يصير في فعالية في الحركة
لأن بالنهاية لما أستخدم الجسم، أنا اللي راح أسوي الحركة
ما في شيء خارجي راح يسوي هذه الحركة
صحيح
وعلى هذا الأساس، العضلة لازم يكون فيها انقباض وإطالة في نفس الوقت
ممتاز، لما تتمرن متى تقدر تعرف
أو هل تقدر تعرف أن هذا الألم اللي جاءك في العضل صحي، وللا إصابة؟
هذا إشكال عند الناس اللي ما يتمرنون
الألم العضلي يفرق واجد عن ألم المفصل
يكون يسمونه الـ(DOMS) أو تأخر ظهور ألم العضلات
هو عبارة عن ألم أو شد أو ألم شد، ما هو ألم المفصل نفسه
ويكون بالعضلة نفسها
لا، ألم الإصابة أو المفاصل واضح، مع الحركة ما تقدر تتحرك
يجيك مدى حركي معين، أنت خلاص هذا فيه ألم
يمكن أقدر أزيد المدى شوي، ولكن في ألم بالمفصل نفسه
أما ألم العضلة لا، مختلف تمامًا من ناحية وصف أو شعور كامل
عند الناس الجديدة على التمرين
تحسب أن إذا صار في ألم بالعضلات، معناته أنا متضرر، ما تفرّق
فيقولون مثلًا في ألم، وهو شد ما هو ألم، فللحين ما جربوا الاثنين
أو ممكن شخص يكون عايش ألم لفترة طويلة ويحوشه شد
صار في عنده ربط ما بين أي شد، بأن هذا سيء
وهذه إشكالية أشوفها خاصةً عند كبار السن مو عند الصغار
لأن الصغار قادرين يفرقون بينهم
المساج، هل هو مفيد، هل كل أنواع المساج مفيدة؟
وإذا في أنواع معينة مختلفة
ودي أتكلم، وأدري أن عندك تجارب برضو...
نعم، أنا من أول الشغلات اللي، كان عندي إصابة في الكتف والكوعين
في الكتفين والكوعين
إصاباتك كثيرة يا أمير
إي والله، يقول لك: باب النجار مخلّع
فوالله كانت هي للبحث عن حل نفسي قبل أي شيء ثاني
فأذكر للحين، عمري 22 في الجامعة، ورحت عند أخصائي علاج طبيعي
كان عندي ألم في الكوعين والكتفين
لأن كنت مستعجل أبي أعضل بسرعة وهذا...
فكان الأسلوب غلط، أذكر الأسلوب اللي سويته في تمرين كتف
فرحت له، أول شيء رحت دكتور
وعندنا عُرف سائد بأن أي ألم بجسمك تروح الدكتور
لا، تقدر تروح حق أخصائي علاج طبيعي
لأن ممكن الدكتور يدخلك بدوامة
تعال أشعة، ولما يشوفها على الأغلب لازم يطلع شيء غلط
لأن أنا إذا أخذت سيارة الحين جديدة، طلعها أسبوع من الوكالة
إذا أخذتها عند الوكالة، راح يقول لك: يبي لها تبديل
لأنه لازم يقول لك شيء، أنا فحصت ولازم يكون في نتيجة
نفس الشيء مع الدكتور، والله أقول لك من واقع تجربة
ومن واقع اللي أشوفه أنا
فروحت الدكتور، غزني كورتيزون في الكوع، وأذكر زاد الألم حزتها
بعد فترة، قالوا لي: أمير روح علاج طبيعي، ورحت
وكان أخصائي العلاج الطبيعي، قعد يستخدم جهاز خارجي
وبعد فترة، سألني سؤال حسسني بإحباط مو طبيعي
قال لي: أنت تبي ترجع تتمرن صح؟
كأن وضعي ميؤوس منه، فحبّطني شيء خيالي
ولكن بعد تقريبًا سنة...
في ناس يحوشها ألم، تتأقلم تقول: هذا وضعي أنا
فقمت أحاتي إذا جاءني عيال، أقدر أشيلهم وللا لا، تخيل لهذه الدرجة
لدرجة أني لما أسوق سيارة، ألبس مثل ضبّابة حول الكوع
على أساس تسوي ضغط، لأقدر أسوق، لهذه الدرجة
فيوم رحت عند أخصائي ثاني، كان «معالج تقويم العمود الفقري»
واللي ما يعرف «المعالج لتقويم العمود الفقري» هو من يطقطق العظام
ولكن ما كان تبع «معالجي تقويم العمود الفقري»
كنت شايف إعلان للاعب فرنسي يلعب بأمريكا اسمه «توني باركر»
ويمدح هذا المركز، فرحت له
فدش علي، عبدالرحمن، شخص طوله متر وخمسة وتسعين أو مترين، يخرّع
قال لي: أمير شنو عندك؟ قلت له: والله ألم كتف، واحد واثنين وثلاث
قلت له: أكثر بالجانب الأيسر
قال لي: الحين بنسوي شغلة احنا، بس راح تكون مؤلمة
قلت له: حسنًا، خذ راحتك، أنا ما عندي غيرك
فمسك أصبعه، من الرسغ عندي إلى الكتف، صعد فوق إلى المثلثات
وحسيت مثل نار، خاصةً عند المثلثات
كررها يمكن خمس أو ست مرات
قمت، قال لي: حرّك يدك، والله أخف
قلت: تمام، قال لي: عندنا احنا في العيادة وعد
إذا أنت بست جلسات ما تحسّنت، فلوسك نردها
قلت له: تم، مو خسران شيء
والجلسة كانت يمكن 220 دولار، حزّتها مبلغ
ورحت، ثلاث جلسات، كأني كذاب*
هذا كان مدخلي للمساج، ترخية العضلات والأنسجة
وهذا المعالج كان سابق وقته
قال لي: أمير أنت تحب الرياضة، وأنت إنسان رياضي
وتلعب كرة سلة، وتبي ترجع شوي شوي
فأنصحك أنك تشترك بهذا الموقع، قلت له: شنو هذا؟
قال لي: هذا راح يحسن المرونة وما أدري أيش، وأعطاني كرة
قال لي، هذا بعد الجلسة الأولى
إذا ما راح تستخدم الكرة كل يوم وترخّي بنفسك، لا تجيني
قلت له: أنا كل يوم برخّي، ما عليك
والله أسبوع وأسبوعين وثلاث، قام ألعب ملاكمة، وأموري ردت طبيعية
فحاشني شعور أن شنو هذه المعاناة لمدة ثلاث سنين
انتهت بأسبوع أو أسبوعين أو ثلاث
ورحت لدكتور، ورحت لـ...
وصرفت فلوس، وقعدت أحاتي المستقبل
فدشيت عبر الإنترنت، وكتبت، شنو أفضل أنواع المساج؟
الحين أنا بتعلم لنفسي
طلع في شيء اسمه علاج رولف، تبع لسيدة اسمها «إيدا رولف»
من جذي أقول لك: المدرسين ما كانوا دارسين لا إخصائي علاج طبيعي ولا شيء
«إيدا رولف» عالمة كيمياء حيوية، كيمياء حيوية دارسة
وابتكرت تقنية في المساج، تشتغل على الجهاز الغشائي
الحين الجهاز الغشائي: هو الشيء اللي يغلف كل أنسجة الجسم
وحتى على مستوى الخلية نفسها
الخلية مغلفة بهذه المادة «الكولاجين» اللي اسمها «فاشا»
إذا أنا شلت العظام والعضلات والدم وخليت بس الجهاز الغشائي
راح ألاقي إنسان كامل عندي
فقالت: أنا بستهدف هذه الـ«فاشا» أو الجهاز الغشائي
اللي هو وقت العمليات يشيلونه، ويقطونه عبالهم ما له أثر
فـ«إيدا رولف» قالت: أنا بإيدي راح أرخّي
أو أغير من طبيعة هذه اللفافة أو الغشاء عشان أغير هيكل الجسم
وهذا الكلام بالـ 1930 أو 1940 يمكن
وعلى أثرها قدرت أنها تغير انحراف العمود الفقري، بإيدها
فهي تعطي مثل أمر لهذه الأنسجة أنها تتحرك بطريقة معينة
وعلى أثرها، على مدى عشر أو اثنى عشر جلسة
الجسم شوي شوي يوازن نفسه، فكانت سابقة وقتها بواجد
ففي هذا النوع من المساج، اللي أنا بعدين رحت ودرسته وتعلمته
بس من مدرسة أخرى، اللي هو تلميذ «إيدا رولف»
«توماس مايرز»
وفي المساج العادي اللي هو ترخيات لكل الجسم
مساج «إيدا رولف» اللي تبع تقييم كامل للجسم
هذا يعيد التوازن للعضلات
وممكن يؤثر على المدى البعيد على قوامك واتزانك
فأحد القصص العجيبة، لـ«توماس مايرز»
اللي هو مؤسس مدرسة «أناتومي ترينز»
يقول: جاءني شخص مغني أوبرا عنده مشكلة في الأحبال الصوتية
فشوية تقصيرًا منه ركّز على بس الجزء العلوي، مبدئيًا
فقال: ما يتحسن الشخص
خلني أعيد النظر بالجسم ككل، أخذ تاريخه، وفحص
شاف أن في مشكلة في الركبة
راح اشتغل على عضلة خلف الركبة اسمها المأبضيَّة، اشتغل عليها
الصوت رد والأحبال الصوتية تمام، وعاش حياته
فعلًا؟
في علاقة عميقة بين العضلات العميقة في الجسم
يسمونه الخط العميق، ممتد هذا من اللسان إلى القدم
ولكن يمر في الحجاب الحاجز والغشاء حول المعدة وعضلات قاع الحوض
والضامة والعضلة الظُنبوبية الخَلفية أو اللي تقوس القدم
إلى القدم للأسفل
عجيب
فهنا هذا النوع من المساج أو العلاج اليدوي
الحين في علاج حركي ويدوي
العلاج اليدوي هذا الـ «أناتومي ترينز» أو يسمونه التكامل الهيكلي
ينظر إلى الجسم ككل، وأحرر أنسجة بيدي
على حسب مكان العلّة اللي أشوفها
مو شرط يكون مكان العلّة هو مكان الألم
مو شرط؟
مو شرط أبدًا، أعطيك مثال
هذه من أواخر الحالات، جاءتني سيدة يمكن في الخمسينات من عمرها
ودشت علي، أول ما دشت لاحظت أن البطن منفوخ
بس البطن منفوخ، هي سيدة ضعيفة، مو متينة، ولا أتوقع أنها حامل
فدشت علي، وقعدنا أخذ تاريخ كامل
لازم أهم خطوة عند أي معالج، يأخذ قصتك كاملة
أنت داش علي إنسان
فيه هموم وإصابات سابقة، لازم أعرفها كلها
فقلت لها: الولادات كلها كانت طبيعية؟
قالت لي: كلها طبيعية إلا آخر واحدة كانت قيصرية
قلت لها: وبعد العملية القيصرية، كان في انفصال عضلي؟
قال: انفصال كبير
أيش تقصد انفصال عضلي؟
انفصال عضلي لما عضلات المعدة تنفصل
والمعدة نفسها تمتد لبرة أو تنتفخ
فيصير في ضعف في عضلات الجذع نفسها
فهي جاءتني مو عشان لا المعدة ولا شيء
جاءتني عشان ألم ظهر كامل من الرقبة إلى العصعص وألم بالقدم
قلت لها: أنا بفحص الجسم كامل
فمن الفحوصات اللي سويتها، هي حركة الضلوع مع الشهيق والزفير
المفروض الضلوع تتحرك للخارج مع الشهيق، خاصةً السفلية
ومع الزفير تدخل للداخل
الضلوع ما تحركت أبدًا للداخل، وكان الانفصال العضلي واضح
ولاحظت أن المدى الحركي في الورك جدًّا محدود
فقلت لها: عطيني شوية ثقة
أنا ما راح أشتغل على ظهرك والورك، ولا شيء
نبني نشتغل على الضلوع والتنفس، ونشوف شو يصير معنا
أي معالج يحط أول شيء فرضيات مبنية على التاريخ والفحوصات
ويجرب، طلع صحيح، صحيح
لأن كل شخص راح يكون معقد جدًّا أنك أنت تعرف 100% شنو المشكلة من الفحص
لازم أجرب، مو جرب والله على أساس أي كلام
لا، أجرب على أساس الفحوصات
فعلى أساس الفحوصات، الضلوع والورك ما يتحركون
وفي علاقة بين حركة الورك والضلوع، بين القفص الصدري والحوض
قلت: تعالي، نامي على جنب
خمس دقائق تنفس مع حركة معينة نسويها بالضلوع
الجانب الثاني، خلنا نقوم
أول ما قامت، قالت: أنا ليش حاسة أني خفيفة؟
ليش ظهري مريح، وقدمي مرتاحة؟
قلت: ما عليه الحين من شعورك، خلنا نشوف شنو صار بالورك
لأن أثر الورك واضح على الظهر
فكانت دوران داخلي أو دروان الورك محدود تقريبًا صفر، ما يتحرك أبدًا
أول ما نامت على ظهرها وحرّكنا الورك، قام يتحرك 15 درجة
قالت: أوف
قلت لها: أنا اللي أقول أوف، لأني ما توقعت هذه النتائج
من خمس دقائق شغل على كل جهة
فمكان الألم، من خلال هذه مدرسة المساج، غير موضع المشكلة
فلازم نشوف وين المشكلة حركيًّا ونروح لها، ما نروح لموضع الألم
لما تروح حق مساج عادي أو رياضي
أقول له: والله ركبي تعورني
راح يمكن يمسّج أو يرخي عضلات الفخذ الأمامية والفخذ الخلفي
ويمكن يصعد للورك، بس ما فحصك، ولا سوى شيء
بس يرخي العضلات، مفيد ما أقول لك: لا، يعطي شوية راحة للعضلة
ويعطيها شوية طول، ولكنها ما هو عمل دقيق لموازنة العضلات
والمساج العادي معروف وين الناس تروح له، بس الثاني؟
المختص هذا، الحين...
وين أروح له؟
أخصائيين العلاج الطبيعي، في ناس مختصة في هذا الموضوع
بالخليج قليلين اللي يمارسون شيء يسمونه التكامل الهيكلي
يمكن في، والله أقرب شخص شفته في...
في شخص في الكويت غيري، وأقرب دولة إيران
بس أنت مو شرط أنك تسوي التكامل الهيكلي
إذا الشخص قرأ جسمك صح، وفاهم ارتباط الجسم
مو شرط أن يلمسك على أساس تتحسن
هو يعطيك تمارين وإرشادات، وفوق عنايته وإرشاداته
ويحقق هذا الترابط اللي نبيه
ممتاز، الجاكوزي حار أو بارد، المياه تفرق حارة أو باردة؟
حق شنو، الألم؟
حق العضلات والألم
نعم، راح تفك الشد
فيه أسلوب معين؟
يمكن عارف أنت سامع في «ويم هوف»؟
«ويم هوف» رحت وقعدت معاه، وأخذت دوراته وهذه الأمور
الماء البارد ميزته أنه يعطيك أثر مضاد الالتهاب
لأنه يفرز هرمونات، ويفرز«سيتوكينات» ومضاد التهاب
وشغلات مضادة للالتهاب، فيعطيك هذا الشعور بأنك متجدّد
ويأثر من ناحية أخرى، الماء البارد على النفسية
شلون يأثر على النفسية، ويخفف من هذه الالتهابات؟
إذا كان عندي ضغط أو ألم أو أي شيء معياره كضغط على جسمي
خلنا نقول: خمسة من عشرة، ما هو مسألة حياة وموت، ما راح أموت الحين
ضغط نفسي، وللا ضغط...؟
الاثنين، الجسدي...
الجسم ما يفرق بين الضغط النفسي وبين الجسدي
جهاز عصبي واحد، وردة فعل وحدة
فخلنا نقول: مستوى هذا الضغط خمسة من عشرة
لما أدخل بالماء البارد، تصير الحين مسألة حياة وموت
أن أنا الحين درجة الحرارة صفر، لازم يكون عندي ردة فعل
فاللي يصير يا أنك أنت تطلع، وتفقد الفوائد
يا أنك تقعد، وتواجه هذا الخوف والصدمة للنظام
وتنزّل جهازك العصبي شوي شوي إلى حالة أنت فيها مرتاح
الحين الهم الأول، أيش صار فيه؟ تلاشى
لأن صارت الحين فعلًا في هَم حياة أو موت
فأنا غيرّت بيئتي خليتها فعلًا مواجهة
وعلى أثرها تنضبط أو منظوري لهذه الأمور ينضبط
وتشوف أغلب الناس يطلعون من حمام بارد، الحياة سعيدة
وهذه كانت تجربتي مع «ويم هوف»
أول شيء...
وخصوصًا «ويم هوف» أحس المفترض أن ما أحد يتابعه
ويسوي أشياء غريبة
صح
أتذكر مقطع شفته يمكن كان لاعب دخل ماء باردة
وكأنه انشل من...
إي، هو لحظة وحدة اللي راح يفرق معاك هذا الموضوع
أنا كنت مؤخرًا في..
أنا آخر مرة مسوي حمام بارد هذا أبو أربع درجات سيليزية
يمكن من سنتين أو ثلاثة، ما أمارسها بشكل مستمر
فعندي صديق وزميل لي هنا، فاتحين مركز «إيكو»
وفي المركز حاطين حمام بارد
أنا آخر ثلاث سنين، تعمقت أكثر...
عندكم بالكويت، وللا بالرياض؟
بالرياض، الشهر اللي طاف الكلام
فآخر ثلاث سنين تعمقت أكثر في التنفس
والفاصل أو الزبدة في تحكم ردة فعلك في الحمام البارد
هي أنك أنت تتحكم في ردة الفعل الأولية، اللي هي الشهقة
إذا جتك الشهقة، ركّز على الزفير كثر ما تقدر
بس طلع زفير، خلي الزفير ستة أو سبعة أو ثمانية ثواني
طلّع زفير، لا تأخد شهيق
اللي تسويه قاعد تأمر جسمك من خلال العصب الحائر بأنه يهدى
فآخر مرة نزلت، ولا كأني نازل بماء بارد
أربع أو خمس، يمكن قعدنا ست أو سبع دقائق، وطلعنا
قبل كنت أسوي الـ«طريقة ويم هوف» أتنفس، وأجهز جسمي وأنزل
الحين لا، أركز على الزفير، وأموري عادي، أسولف وطبيعي
فالحكمة في الزفير
الزفير
نعم
أنا متحمس أني أبغى أروح للتنفس، بس ودي أقفل كم ملف
أكيد
عشان نخلي التنفس آخر شيء
عندك دورة خاصة بس في الزفير
الزفير موضوع آخر
ودي الرقبة والأكتاف، ليش تصير للرقبة آلام؟
هنا لازم ندخل في التنفس
والله؟
إي
عادي ادخل واطلع
شوف أغلب مشاكل...
أتوقع كلها متشابكة، فخذ راحتك
نعم، أغلب مشاكل، هذا ما أدري إذا مثبت علميًّا وللا لا
بس هذا عن واقع تجربة
ما أدري إذا في دراسات عن هذا الموضوع
بس أشوف أغلب الناس عندهم مشكلة بالرقبة
لما تأخذ تاريخهم، هنا شلون أقول له تأخذ تاريخهم؟
اذكر لي الأحداث اللي صارت حول الإصابة
مثلًا الإصابة صارت شهر فبراير اللي طاف
قل لي شنو صار شهر يناير وديسمبر
فوق الـ 50% منهم يذكر أن صار في حدث نفسي أو اجتماعي
أو على مستوى الوظيفة، قوي
فكان في ضغط عالي حزّتها، ومن بعدها بدأت تطلع آلام الرقبة
الحين أمير شنو العلاقة؟
العلاقة، هنا مدخل التنفس
لما جهازك العصبي يصير مشحون
مشحون يعني يصير، في شيء يسمونه الجهاز السمبثاوي يصير مشحون
الجهاز العصبي ينفصل إلى سمبثاوي، ولا سمبثاوي
وظيفة الجهاز العصبي الأساسية، إبقائك على قيد الحياة
فيا أنت مرتاح تهضم ومستانس وتضحك
يا أنه في خطر أو ضغط تنحاش منه أو تواجهه
الجهاز العصبي مربوط ارتباط مباشر في التنفس
لما تكون أنت متوتر، تذكّر أي موقف أنت عصبت فيه
أو كان شوية وتتهاوش، تنفسك يزيد
يروح من مثلًا 12-16-20 عدّة في الدقيقة إلى ثلاثين
الوتيرة تزيد على طول، وليش تزيد؟
عشان دقات قلبي تزيد، وألبي احتياجي الطاغي لمواجهة هذا الضغط
فهو بالأساس احتاج الطاقة، تزيد دقات القلب، القليكوجين أستهلكه أكثر
الإنسولين يرتفع، والأدرينالين ينضخ في الجسم
على أساس يا أنحاش يا أواجه
الحين إذا طولت هذه السالفة، خلنا نقول ضغط اجتماعي
حالة طلاق، راح أطول أشهر
أنا دائمًا راح أكون في نوعًا ما في هذه الحالة السمبثاوية المشحونة
وعلى أثرها عدّات تنفسي تزداد
لما عدّات تنفسي تزداد راح أستخدم العضلات الثانوية للتنفس
العضلات الأساسية للتنفس: الحجاب الحاجز وعضلات الضلوع
العضلات الثانوية: عضلات الرقبة والمثلثات
ممكن بعد عضلات الصدر تساعدني شوي
فيصير في وضع الضغط هذا استهلاك للعضلات الثانوية على أنها أساسية
وتجهد مع الوقت، ويظهر عندي أغلب الوقت ألم الأبهر
ألم الأبهر لو تتبع مكان اتصال عضلات الرقبة تصل إلى الضلوع
والضلوع تمتد من الأمام إلى الخلف
فأحس فيه كأنه عند لوح الكتف، ولكنه مو هذا مصدره
ونرجع لمقولة أن مكان الألم ما هو مكان المشكلة
فنشوف واجد من مشاكل الرقبة، خلنا شوي بعيد عن الأكتاف
مشاكل الرقبة لها عامل نفسي، كأنه عندي حمل على عاتقي، شايل الهم
وتنفسي يتغير، وعلى أثر هذه العضلات الضعيفة الصغيرة
اللي مو المفروض تكون عضلات أساسية للتنفس، تصير أساسية
تُجهد، وتشكل لي هذا الألم اللي أحس فيه
فعلى الأرجح، آلام الرقبة تكون ممكن نفسية أكثر من أنها...
نعم، تشوف ناس واجد يجونك مع تقارير
مثلًا التصوير بالرنين المغناطيسي، وما فيه شيء
شنو السبب؟ ترجع بالتاريخ تلاقي في مسبب
أغلب حالات الرقبة في مسبب
من أقربها الرقبة والأبهر
سيدة عندها آلام رقبة وكتف، لما أخذنا التاريخ
لقينا أنها تزوجت قبل الألم، وعلاقتها الزوجية جيدة وكل شيء
وانتقلت إلى المدينة الجديدة
والمدينة الجديدة غريبة عليها، وكانت خائفة أنها تترك أهلها
وبلشت المشكلة
فتزامن النقلة ما هو صدفة
لأن نشوفها مرة ومرتين وثلاثة مع الناس
فهنا يدخل العامل النفسي
أنا إذا دائمًا في ذهني في وضعية كرّ وفرّ أو مواجهة
لضغط أو لخوف غير متواجد وغير واقعي
ما هو أسد راح يأكلني، لازم أغير الفكر
نقدر نغير الفكر أو ردة فعليي أو قدرة تحملي عن طريق العلاج النفسي
والاستشارات، هذه موضوع آخر
أو عن طريق التنفس، أني أقدر أوسّع قدرتي على تحمل هذا الضغط
فممكن يكون حلها بالطبيب النفسي أو معالج نفسي
أو عن طريق التنفس؟
نعم، قارنوا تأثير الأدوية على مرضى الـ«بي تي إتش دي»
اللي هو الضغط ما بعد الصدمات
هذه اللي طالعين من حروب، أو صدمات عاطفية
اعتداء في الطفولة وغيرها، كله يشكل «بي تي إتش دي»
أو الصدمات هذه
فقارنوا أثر الدواء للـ«بي تي إتش دي»
مع نوع معين من التنفس، وشافوا أنه نفس الأثر
لأن هذا الشخص عالق في وضعية في جهازه العصبي مستمرة
الأحداث تتكرر
ولما هذه الأحداث الوهمية اللي خلصت تتكرر في ذهني
جسمي يصدقها
لذلك أنت لما تشاهد فلم تخاف أو تبكي أو تضحك
وهم، خيال صح؟
صدق
فالجسم ما يفرق بين الواقع والخيال، صح؟
فالحادثة تتكرر، فلما تتكرر فزيولوجيًّا صار في فصل عندهم
صار عندهم شحنة سمباثاوية، مشحون دائمًا الجهاز العصبي
وما صار عندهم مدخل إلى الراحة
شلون ندخلهم إلى الراحة؟
عن طريق التركيز على الزفير
ولما نركز على الزفير، نفعّل عصب اسمه العصب الحائر
اللي هو يأمر الجسم بأنه يرتاح، دقات القلب تنزل والهضم يرجع عادي
والتنفس وتيرته تقل
ويرجع شوي شوي جسمه من ناحية كيميائية
يتغير حمض الدم عنده، يتغير شوي شوي على المدى البعيد
ويستقر ويقدر يتعايش مع أحداثه اليومية
عجيب، بالنسبة للرقبة، ليش أحيانًا مثلًا في الصلاة
إذا كانت صلاة طويلة، يجي آلام في الرقبة؟
كذا تحس أنك تتعب
أغلب الناس بسبب الوضعية اللي احنا قاعدين فيها
عضلات أعلى الظهر غير فعالة عندهم عند الوقوف
احنا عند الوقوف لازم أكون كثر ما أقدر في مشاركة
ما بين عضلات الفخذ الخلفي، والأرداف، وأسفل وأعلى الظهر
أغلب الناس في أعلى الظهر ما عندهم تفعيل
فلو تلاحظ أقرب شيء للرقبة هي عضلات أعلى الظهر
فإذا قدرت أفعل عضلات أعلى الظهر أكثر
الرقبة راح يكون عليها ضغط أقل
قوامي بعد شوي يصير فيه توازن أكثر ما بين الرقبة والقدم
لذلك أقول لك: في خلاف على الموضوع
الحين أنا أقف فترة طويلة، هذه وضعية أنا ثابت فيها
وقاعد تأثر على ألمي، فمو معقول أني أقول أن وضعية القوام
أو الطريقة اللي أقعد أو أوقف فيها ما تأثر
صح
فمشاركة الحمل ما بين أعلى الظهر والرقبة راح يخفف الألم عنها
في الركوع، دام دخلنا على الصلاة
تثني ركبتك، وللا أفضل أنك تمدها؟
الحين السنة وللا؟
لا، صحة
إذا صحة، المفروض يكون عندك القابلية على الاثنين
لا، ثني الركبة لا يعني...
أمر خاطئ؟
لا، أنك سوء في صحتك الحركية؟
ثني الركبة معناته عضلات الفخذ الخلفي عندك
وممكن البطات والعضلات العميقة للأرداف، تكون مشدودة
أنا لازم يكون عندي قابلية على أني لما أركع، ركبتي تكون سيدا
ويمكن شوي أكثر من سيدا، تكون ممدودة شوي للوراء
هذا الشيء مطلوب لجسم الإنسان
مو معناته إذا سويت العكس، من تلقاء نفسي شيء سيء
ولكن لازم يكون عندي القابلية على الاثنين
في اللي يقول لك برضو، وأتذكر هذه من «الشقيري»
أحس «الشقيري» حضر مرتين
هذه الحلقة فيها واجد أغلاط
والله؟
نعم
فأن إذا أنت، عرفت الإطالة اللي تنزل إلى رجلك
بس تكون رجلك ممدودة
نعم
فأنه كلما قدرت كلما زاد، معناته أن صحتك...
غير صحيح
غير صحيح؟
غير صحيح 100%
الله يهديك يا أستاذ «أحمد»
أحمد من أكبر المؤثرين، وكل التقدير له على اللي سواه
يمكن للحين هذه الفكرة موجودة من أخصائيين نفسهم
ما نلوم «أحمد» الفكرة منتشرة
بس ما في علاقة بين المرونة والصحة
أبدًا؟
لا، بمعنى كلما زادت مرونتي زادت صحتي؟ لا
أعطيك مثال، في واجد من مدربات اليوقا يعانون في صمت
واحدة منهم طلعت، وتكلمت بالموضوع اسمها «جيل ميلر»
من أكبر مدربات ومعلمات اليوقا في أمريكا
من كثر ما تسوي إطالات، معناته في مدى حركي كامل في الفخذ والركبة
فقد الورك عندها قابليته على الوظيفة الصحيحة
ما صار يتحرك بشكل صحيح
فبعد فترة صار في ألم شديد، وسوت إطالة زيادة عن اللزوم للورك
واضطرت أنها تسوي عملية تبديل ورك
في عمر يمكن الثلاثينات أو الأربعينات، جدًّا صغير
وكله كان نتيجة أنه هي عندها مرونة، وفوقها تزيد عليها مرونة
فالجسم فقط قابليته على الانقباض، صار كله مرن بمرن
صار كأنه معكرونة، ما في أي أنسجة تثبته، فهنا الإشكالية
في مؤشرات سليمة للمدى الحركي، ما نبي نتخطاها
إلا إذا رياضتي تتطلب هذا الشيء
بس حق الشخص العادي، لا مو معناه كلما صار عندك مرونة زيادة
معناتها صحتك أفضل، لا
لما تطق الرقبة وللا ظهرك، أو أحد يطق لك إياها
تعرف هذه الحركة اللي يقول
مقوّم العظام
الناس تسويها، أو لما يمسكك، ويشدك كذا إلى أن تسمعه
إلى أن يطق، قصدك شنو أثرها، هل هي زينة أو لا؟
هل هي زينة، ليش تحس بعدها براحة؟
والله في علم كامل على هذا
دوبي طاقها قبل شوي سويت زي كذا
ممكن اللي يصير معك أنت على أساس تطق ظهرك
أو خلنا نقول: تسوي الحركة العكسية
أن مستشعرات الحركة عندك في العضلات، تقول لك: طولت سوي العكس
نفس القطة لما تقعد، فجأة تلاقيها مغطت نفسها وردّت
هذه مستشعرات الحركة عندها، قالت لها: سوي هذه الحركة
فأول ما تقعد من النوم الصبح، شلون تتمغط، لا إراديًّا
فتسوي الحركة العكسية
أما علم...
أيش الصوت اللي يطلع لما تطق هذه، هل هي...؟
فقاعة هواء
مو الفقرات...؟
لا، فقاعة هوا نفسها
في طق فقرات، بس هذا علم كامل اللي هو مقوّم العظام
ما عندي دراية كافية فيه أني أحكم والله
بس المفترض الواحد ما يسويها بنفسه؟
اللي يطقها
رقبته، هل هي لها مخاطر، ما أدري
عادي أقول: ما أدري صح؟
لا مو عادي، المفروض أنك تفتي، هنا الفكرة
قلت: عدّل حركتك، يتعدّل نومك
أيش علاقة الحركة بالنوم؟
أنت لما تعدّل حركتك
معناته الضغط على المفاصل نفسها وتوزيع الحمل يتوزع
فالحِمل نفسه على الجسم يخف
فعلى أثرها جسمك ما راح يكون شايل ضغط أو الشد لفترة طويلة
خلال اليوم، ويقدر يريح
وأنت تشوف في التنويم المغناطيسي، أيش يسوون عبدالرحمن
ما أدري إذا مجربه، وللا لا
ولكن التنويم المغناطيسي
أبدًا، هل هو حقيقي أصلًا؟
نعم
والله؟
علم كامل من زمان، والحين صاروا يدخلونه في العيادات
أنا مجرب التنويم المغناطيسي أربع مرات
أقرب شيء للسحر هو التنويم المغناطيسي، لتغيير العادات
فعلًا تنام؟
نعم، تنام بس هي ما بين النوم
هي حالة «ثيتا» ما بين النوم والاستيقاظ
أنت سامع كل شيء، بس بنفس الوقت نايم
وفعلًا لما يقول لك: ثلاثة واثنين وواحد، تقوم
إي، بس من طرق تنويمك مغناطيسيًّا أو تريح الجسم
ودخوله في هذا الـ«ثيتا ستايت» ذهنيًّا
أنه يمر على جزء جزء من جسمك
ويقول لك: رَخ الأكتاف، والكوع، والرسغ، والكوع والركبة وغيره
وتلاقي نفسك شوي شوي ارتخيت، ونمت
فإذا عندي جسم أنا مشدود أربعة وعشرين ساعة في ضغط
لسبب نفسي أو حركي أو أيًّا، راح يكون في صعوبة أكثر عليه على الاسترخاء
فهذا الربط من ناحية جهاز عصبي
ممتاز، تقول: التنفس الوظيفي السليم يحول الهواء إلى دواء
نعم
أول شيء، ما هو التنفس الوظيفي؟
ممتاز، تعريف التنفس الوظيفي كالتالي
يرجع إلى جزء ميكانيكي حيوي، شلون تتنفس
وجزء آخر كيميائي أو كيميائي حيوي
اللي هي تدخل في عدّات التنفس اللي تأخذها
وتحمّلك لثاني أكسيد الكربون، وأمور أخرى
من ناحية الميكانيكا الحيوية، من ناحية حركية لما أخذ النفس
المفروض الجسم من تلقاء نفسه
هذا إذا بنعتبر النفس وظيفي نفسه
الضلوع السفلية تتوسع بشكل 360 درجة
الضلوع السفلية: هي تحت عند الخواصر، تتوسع بشكل 360 درجة
والجزء العلوي من الصدر، ينتفخ شوي للأمام
لازم هذين المتطلبين، على أساس أعرف أن
الجسم يأخذ الهواء بأقل مجهود، ما يكون في ضغط على جزء أكثر من آخر
الحين للناس اللي عندهم مثلًا مشاكل بالأكتاف
نلاقي بأن في تنفس سطحي، ولما يأخذ النفس أكتافه ترتفع، لفوق
ما يأخذ النفس من غير ما يحرك أكتافه
فهنا نلاقي أن العنصر الحركي مهم لصحة الأكتاف والرقبة
وهذا أهم شيء أقيمه عند أي شخص عنده مشكلة بالكتف والرقبة
من ناحية كيميائية نشوف وتيرة التنفس
الشخص كم نفس يأخذ في الدقيقة؟
ما في اتفاق علمي بأن هذا العدد هو السليم
ولكن نشوف ما بين ثمانية وستة إلى ثمانية عشر
أكثر من ذلك، أعرف الشخص اللي أمامي يتنفس زيادة عن اللزوم
شنو يعني يتنفس زيادة عن اللزوم؟
يعني عنده شيء يسمونه حالة فرط تهوية
أو تنفس في الدقيقة فوق الثمانية عشر أو عشرين عدّة في الدقيقة
أيش اللي يسويه هذا في الجسم؟
يزيد مستوى الأكسجين في الدم
لما يزيد مستوى الأكسجين في الدم، حمض الدم نفسه يتغير
يصير قلوي أكثر
يمكن واجد تسمع بأن القلوي شيء زين
التوازن شيء زين، اللي هو حمض الدم يكون بين 7.35 إلى 7.45
شوف الدقة، لازم يكون في هذا الحد
إذا صار قلوي أكثر، اللي يصير بأن الأكسجين يظل في الدم
مع الهيموقلوبين والخلايا، يتشبّث فيها
معناته تقل نسبة الأكسجين اللي تروح للأنسجة
فلازم نعادل هذا الشيء عن طريق التركيز على الزفير
على أساس يكون عندي ثاني أكسيد الكربون أعلى في الجسم
تتراوح عدّات التنفس في الدقيقة بين شخص وشخص
نلاقي أن في لاعبين يوقا يوصلون إلى ست عدات في الدقيقة
هو تقريبًا كل اثنى عشر ثانية، يأخذ خمس عدات
كل عشر ثواني، يأخذ نفس واحد
فخمسة شهيق وخمسة زفير، يسمونه هذا النفس الذهبي
وفي ناس بالاثنى عشر والأربعة عشر وضعها طبيعي
عادةً نشوف كلما زادت وتيرة التنفس كلما قابلية تحمل الضغط قلّت عند الجسم
في دراسة حديثة سمّوا ثاني أكسيد الكربون بأنه جزيء الإجهاد
أو هذه الجزيئة هي اللي تسبب لي الضغط في الجسم
ما أدري ليش أخذ ثاني أكسيد الكربون على أنه شيء سلبي
نعم، لكن هو كله عن الموازنة
بالعكس، إذا ما عندي ثاني أكسيد الكربون مستحيل الأنسجة تستقبل الأكسجين
فتخيل الجسم عنده مستشعرات لثاني أكسيد الكربون
وهي اللي تخليك تتنفس
في شيء بقاع المخ اسمه الـ«بوتسينكر كومبلكس»
هذا يحدد كمية ثاني أكسيد الكربون عندك في الدم
إذا ارتفعت، هنا تأخذ الشهيق، مو العكس
يعني مو إذا نزل الأكسجين، لا إذا ارتفع ثاني أكسيد الكربون
ففي الدراسة اللي صارت
اللي قالت: أن ثاني أكسيد الكربون هو جزيئة الخوف
كان على امرأة عندها مشكلة في جزء من المخ اسمه «اللوزة الدماغية»
«اللوزة الدماغية» هذه هي تعطيك استشعار للخوف
هذه غير موجودة عندها، استشعار الخوف غير موجود عندها
ما أذكر لخلل فيها أو فقدان جزء منها، ما أذكر بالضبط
بس هذه الامرأة ما تخاف من ولا شيء
ورّوها أفاعي وحريقة ما تخاف، ما تخاف من ولا شيء
وصار لها حادثة تم خطفها والاعتداء عليها، وما كان في أي ردّة فعل
وما كان فيه أي خوف
فما تخاف من الغرباء
فقالوا: بنأخذها، ونحقنها بثاني أكسيد الكربون
راح نحقن فيها كمية بسيطة من ثاني أكسيد الكربون
أول ما حقنوا فيها ثاني أكسيد الكربون، حاشتها حالة هلع
قالت: وقفوا، رجاءً ردوني لوضعي الطبيعي، أنا خائفة وأنا مدري شنو
أول مرة تحس في خوف في حياتها
فكلما تحملك لثاني أكسيد الكربون زاد، تحمّلك، مو مستواه
كلما تحملك لثاني أكسيد الكربون زاد؛ كلما أعصابك هدت أكثر
وكان عندك قابلية على تحمل الضغط
في تمارين تخليني أرفع من زيادة...؟
نعم، كلما طولت في حبس النفس والزفير
فمثلًا في شيء جدًا شائع اللي هو 4-7-8
4 شهيق، 7 أحبس النفس، بعدين 8 زفير
أنا شوي شوي جذي أزيد تحملي لثاني أكسيد الكربون
في طريقة أخرى، الـ 4-7-8 ما يناسب الكل لأنه مستواه شوي عالي
اللي أقدر أسويه، أسوي شيء يسمونه تنفس الصندوق
أبلش أول شيء عدّتين راح يكون عدّتين شهيق
عدتين وقفة، عدتين زفير، عدتين وقفة، وأعيد
فتصير على شكل صندوق أو مربع
قدرت أستحمل العدتين، عادي وضعك طبيعي
لا أنك اضطريت أنك توقف ولا شيء، أروح إلى الثلاث عدات
أسوي العدتين على مدى مثلًا دقيقتين، أشوف وضعي تمام
أروح للثلاث عدات
وضعي بالثلاث عدات ممتاز، أروح للأربع عدات
والمستوى اللي أقوف عنده...
خلنا نقول: أنا الحين أقدر خمسة بخمسة بخمسة بخمسة، ووضعي طبيعي
شفت أن الستة صعبة علي، أبلش أمارس الأربع عدات
اللي هي أقل من مستواي العالي
اللي أقدر عليه
أربع عدات لمدة عشر دقائق في الليلة
كل ليلة؟
كل ليلة، إلى ما تشوف أنت وضعك...
هنا الإشكال دائمًا نقول: لمتى؟ الإنسان متغير
أنا أحيانًا يكون عندي ضغوطات أو أمر بحالات، أو تصير لي ظروف فقد ولا غيره
جسمي وحياتي كلها تتغير، فأعيد تقييم نفسي
وأشوف شنو اللي أحتاجه حزتها
أنا مجهد مثلًا اليوم، أنت عندك تصوير من الصبح إلى الليل
أحط لي عشر دقائق، وأخلي التلفون على صوب، أبلش أتنفس
لأن أدري بكرة عندي يوم مهم
وبهذا الشكل أحسن من ثاني أكسيد الكربون عندي
كيف أعرف أني أتنفس بشكل صحيح؟
لما تروح عند الدكتور، عبدالرحمن
وين يحط عادةً السماعة؟
على الصدر
على الصدر أو الظهر
على الظهر من فوق
لأن النفس لازم، في شيء يسمونه الفجوة الخلفية للصدر
الهواء يصل لها، ويصير فيها انتفاخ
فبكل بساطة، أنت قاعد عادي، تحط يديك على ضلوعك
وإذا أخذت شهيق، هل تشوف في توسع بين الأصابع، وللا لا؟
المفروض الأصابع تروح بشكل، تسويها الحين؟
ما أدري
المفروض تشوف في توسع بشكل جانبي للضلوع
حسنًا
وما تشوف ارتفاع واجد بالصدر، نفس ما أنت تسوي
ما يكون في ارتفاع بهذا الشكل
يكون في توسع من غير حركة، ومن ناحية أخرى الأكتاف ما ترتفع
والنقطة الثالثة: بأن الجزء الأمامي والخلفي من الصدر
شوي ينتفخ أو يصير فيه تحرك
شلون أعرف أنا الجزء الخلفي يتحرك؟
نام على ظهرك على الأرض وجربها
حسيت في ضغط من الأرض عليك لما تنفّست
معناته في مساحة قاعدة تصير عندك
من ناحية أخرى، بكل بساطة عيّر لك ثلاثين ثانية أو دقيقة
وشوف من غير ما تتحكم، كم نفس تأخذ في الدقيقة؟
ما في شيء متفق عليه
بس أن ما بين الثمانية إلى الأربعة عشر وستة عشر طبيعي
فوقه يعتبر عندك حالة فرط تهوية أو كثرة في الشهيق والزفير
خليني أشوف بحاول إذا عندي تطبيق الصحة
يعطيك صح؟
أتوقع، أتذكر نسبة الأكسجين بالدم 97% ما أدري صحية ولا؟
نعم صحية
كذا ممتاز؟
خلني أعطيك، معدل التنفس عندي 16.27؟
ستة عشر؟
من 16.8
إلى
27.5
السبعة وعشرين راح تكون يمكن لما تسولف
والله؟
إي طبيعي، لأن طبيعي لازم أطلع...
أنا الحين لما أتكلم، أطلع زفير، فعدّات الشهيق والزفير أخذها أعلى
فهذا المدى حقي من ستة عشر إلى السبعة وعشرين
عالي السبعة وعشرين
والله؟
أنت شوف...
نفس في الدقيقة؟
نعم، حلو لو أنت مراقب هذا العدد خلال اليوم والشغل والنوم والراحة
إذا بالراحة توصل سبعة وعشرين، لا في شيء غلط، مخك شغّال
خلنا نشوف في النوم
طيب نوم، هنا النوم
شوف وقت النوم بعد شوي يرتفع لأنك نايم على ظهرك
يصير يمكن أربعة عشر
أنت ستة عشر، إذا ارتفع واجد إلى العشرين أو اثنين وعشرين هنا...
أنت شوف الأيام هذه، راقب نفسك الأسبوع الجاي
نعم، شوف يوم التصوير أيش يصير، ويوم اللي عندك ضغوطات واجتماعات
ووقت التمرين؟
وقت التمرين طبيعي راح يرتفع هذا شيء عادي
بس أن أنا قاعد، مثلًا قبل اللقاء، طبيعي يكون عندي توتر
على طول القارمن، تقول لي: استرخي، أنت متوتر
لأن تعرف من الـ«إتش آر في» معدل تغير نبضات القلب
وتعرف من (Reception Rate)* فتعطيك تنبيه
النبض بوقت الراحة اثنين وخمسين نبضة في الدقيقة
حلو، ممتاز
هذه ممتاز
نعم، الـ«إتش آر في» عندك؟ بالـ«أورا» يبين
110 «إتش آر في» والمعدل مالك الطبيعي كم؟
الحد الأعلى 145، هذا المعدل أتوقع
بس المدى مالك شنو عادةً؟
في معدل صحي لكل شخص، مختلف عن شخص لشخص
ما أدري، هذا اللي طالع، من 110 لـ116
حسنًا، هو مو عدد مطلق، ما أقدر أقارن نفسي بنفسك
مثلًا أنا الطبيعي عندي من ستين إلى سبعين، 160 لـ80
ففي ناس عندهم طبيعي «إتش آر في» عالي
بس يقيص نفسك بنفسك
فيعطيك أنت المعدل العالي مالك، وبعدين يشوف أنت وقت الراحة شنو
ويعطيك المدى الجيد
عجيب، عندي اللياقة القلبية، تحت المتوسط
يبي لك ركض، يبي لك وادي حنيفة
لا والله، عجيب ما أدري، بشتغل على الموضوع
عجبك وادي حنيفة؟
ممتاز
والله؟
الجو الصراحة
أنتوا عندكم حديقة الشهداء رائعة
حديقة الشهيد
الشهيد
إي حديقة الشهيد حلوة، بس صناعية هذا عيبها
أما وادي حنيفة تروح تشم ريحة مزارع
توه أقول لـ«أيمن» مزارع ونزول وصعود
صح
عرفت علي
في الدرج، جربت تطلعه؟
لا ما مداني للحين، هنا تبين الصحة القلبية
لأنه يمكن ولا 100 درجة
عندي صديقة اسمها «منى شهاب» تعرفها؟
لا
اللي تسلّقت إفرست، تصعد، هي هاوية هذا الشي، تصعد وتنزل
الله يقويها، تصعد لحالها
إي تصعد بروحها
وتصور إنستقرام
فعزمتني قالت: امشي نصعد، قلت: لا مو وقته
في اللي يتنفس عن طريق الفم؟
أيش الفرق بين التنفس عن طريق الفم والأنف؟
هل الشهيق والزفير، تأخذ من الأنف وتطلع من الفم؟ عطني
وقت الراحة الاثنين من الأنف، 100%
فائدة الأنف أن أول شيء يفلتر ويعقم الهواء
ويفرز مادة أكسيد النيتريك من الجيوب، وهذه جدًّا مهمة
لأنها تخفض الضغط
وهي نفس المادة اللي استخدموها بعد اكتشاف أثرها على الجسم
في الفياقرا، فتوسع الشرايين
وهم أكسيد النيتريك مضاد للاتهاب
فعندنا هذه الخاصية بالأنف، ما عندنا إياها في الفم
الأنف يعطيك شوية ضغط خلفي أو ضغط، لأن الفتحات أقل
فالهواء يوصل إلى مناطق أعمق أو الجزء الأسفل من الرئتين، وتستفيد منه أكثر
متى تتنفس من الفم؟
تتنفس من الفم في حالات الشدة العالية
بس؟
إي، «براين ماكنزي»
هو أحد العلماء في علم النَفَس، وتأثيره على الصحة الرياضية
عنده شيء بسيط جدًّا يوضح لك متى لازم تتنفس من الأنف، ومتى من الفم
يقول لك: أنت، في شيء يسمى نظام «القير»
وقت الراحة من الأنف، الشدة شوية ارتفعت
دقات القلب وصلت إلى 110-120 للحين من الأنف
صارت أعلى وصلت إلى 150-160 مو قادر تستحمل
شهيق من الأنف، وزفير من الفم
180-190 وفوق، فم-فم، شهيق فم...
لأن الحين أنا مو وقت صحة، وقت أداء
أبي أخذ أكبر عدد أكسجين وأطلع كل ثاني أكسيد الكربون اللي عندي
على أساس أقدر أصمد في السباق أو الرياضة اللي أسويها
ولما أنزل عشان الاستشفاء، أسوي العكس
فأكون ركضت سباق 400 متر، راح أكون واصل حدي
راح يكون من الفم
إذا بنزل، أنزل إلى من فم-فم إلى أنف-فم إلى أنف-أنف إلى ما أريح
وأعوّد نفسي على هذا النمط
ممتاز، بالنسبة للنوم؟
أنف
أنف؟
إي، لأن التنفس من الفم هو يسبب الشخير والاختناق النومي
ولازم نربط شغلتين ببعض هنا، عبدالرحمن، واجد مهمين
أنت في وضعيات أو حالات الضغط
الحالات لما يكون جهازي العصبي مشحون
تلقائيًّا الجسم يبي يوظّف طاقة أكثر، فيتحول إلى تنفس فموي
هذا النظام فيه «تغذية أمامية» و«تغذية رجعية»
أنا أقدر بسبب الموقف اللي أنا فيه يتغير التنفس
ولكن في نفس الوقت إذا غيرت التنفس راح تغيّر حالتي الفيسيولوجية
فإذا تنفست من فمي، تلقائيًّا أعطي إشارات لجهازي العصبي أن في ضغط
لذلك تلاقي الناس اللي يتنفسون من الفم
زياراتهم، يعزك الله، للحمام عالية بالليل
لأن أيش يصير؟
لما يحوشك ضغط، الجسم يقول لك: فرّغ المثانة
هذه خاصية موجودة على أساس إذا أنت واجهت ذئب ولا شيء
تكون أخف تفرغ المثانة وتركض
فنفس الصفة الموجودة في الجهاز العصبي من 1000 سنة موجودة حاليًا
ما صار في تحسين، نفس الشيء بالضبط
فلما أتنفس من الفم، أعطي إشارة للجهاز العصبي، أن أنا الحين مشحون
وعلى أثرها كل شيء يشتغل مع بعض
دقات القلب تزيد والمثانة ودها، أعزك الله، تفرّغ، فأروح الحمام
في عندي سيدة، تقول لي: يا أمير أنا تبهدلت، ثمانية مرات أروح الحمام
فيقولون: من السكر ومن غيره، قلت لها: خلنا نجرب التالي
تقول: أنا أشرب ماء واجد، أقول لها: تشربين ماء واجد لأن حلقك ناشف
لأنه مبطل خلال اليوم، نجرب بس عشر دقائق من اللي وصفت لك إياه
صندوق التنفس، وقبلها في شغلات لتسليك الأنف وغيره
عشر دقائق أو ربع ساعة قبل النوم، ونشوف كم مرة، أعزك الله، تروحين للحمام
تقدر تعطيني تجربة كذا...
صندوق التنفس؟
بكل بساطة حط توقيت عشر دقائق، وحط التليفون على صوب
أربع ثواني شهيق، أربع ثواني حبس
أو أربع ثواني أخذ الشهيق على أربع عدات، بعدين أربع ثواني أوقف
بعدين أربع ثواني زفير، فأبطئ الزفير
بعدين أربع ثواني أوقف مرة ثانية من غير نفس، وأكرر، عشر دقائق
كلها من الأنف؟
كلها من الأنف، لأني أبي أعطي إشارة لجسمي أن نبي نريح الحين
مو فم، نشحن
فعشر دقائق أو ربع ساعة، شفتها الأسبوع اللي بعده
قلت لها: بشري كم مرة رحتي الحمام؟
قالت لي: أربع مرات، أربع أيام من الأسبوع ما رحت ولا مرة
فراح من الثمانية إلى صفر
فتخيل أنت منظومة العلاج الطبيعي أو الصحة أو العلاج
معتمدة علي كأني أنا أعالج الشخص، ولكن في جانب الاستشفاء
إذا الشخص ما يأخذ جودة نوم عالية، ما راح يصير في استشفاء تام
وهذا المدخل احنا ندخل منه من خلال التنفس
فكلما تنفسي صار أفضل، زادت جودة النوم
وتصير حلقة، جهازي العصبي يرتاح أكثر وأكثر
عجيب، ومثلًا إذا سويت تمرين الصندوق
يأخذ ممكن كم يوم ويصير نومي، لأني ما أتحكم بنفسي بالنوم
وأنت نايم صح ما تقدر
فهذا يساعد؟
أكيد
على طول؟
نعم، في تجارب عديدة جدًّا من تطبيق واحد فقط
ترخي جهازك العصبي ودقات قلبك، وتيرة التنفس
العصب الحار يشتغل وتدخل بنوم أعمق
وهذه التجربة من يوم واحد فقط، ممارسة مرة واحدة
دائمًا الناس ما تفهم أهمية هذا الموضوع إلا لما تجربها
لما تجرب وتحس بالفرق
هنا راح تلاقي أن جودة النوم أعلى، وأنت تقوم متجدّد
مو المفروض، عبدالرحمن، تقوم من النوم وأنت متكسر
أنا نائم، ليش متكسر؟
صح
ولا المفروض تقوم من النوم، وأنت حلقك ناشف
المفروض تقوم جاهز أنك تبلش اليوم، أغلب الناس تجربتها عكس ذلك
وأرجح أن أكثر شيء يأثر على هذا الشيء، هو الجهاز العصبي وشحنته
لذلك أنا أقول: تحسين التنفس، مو لهدف التنفس
أنا مالي شغل بالتنفس
أنا أبي أفضل استشفاء للشخص، وهو نايم
ويتحقق هذا الشيء من خلال ممارسته التنفس
أيش هو التنفس السمعي؟
التنفس السمعي، في شخص اسمه «كارل ستاو»
نرجع إلى الأخصائيين اللي ما لهم علاقة بالمجال
«كارل ستاو» كان أخصائي معني في تحسين الصوت
يجونه الناس حق أوبرا أو ما أوبرا، أو مغنيين يحسّن من صوتهم
لاحظ «كارل ستاوا» أن لما نحسّن من الصوت، النفس يتحسن
وشُهِر بهذا الموضوع في نيويورك
وعلى أثره كان حزتها في مرضى أنفازيما
أنفازيما، مرض يحوش الرئتين، وما له حل
كوظيفة تعيدها للرئتين، ما لها حل
بس قالوا الأطباء: «كارل ستوا» عُرف بأنه يحسّن من التنفس
خلينا نجيبه نشوف أيش يسوي «كارل ستوا»
فجابوه للمستشفى، وقالوا له: نبيك تشتغل على هؤلاء المرضى
هؤلاء المرضى نايمين، ما يصعدون وينزلون من الدرج
عدّات قليلة يأخدونها في اليوم، وما يأكلون لأن في مشكلة تنفس
فأنا أخاف أن يصير في شيء، لما آكل أختنق، فصحتهم جدًّا سيئة
فلاحظ «كارل ستاوا» أول ما وصل
بأن أغلبهم حاطينهم على ظهورهم
وفي مخدة تحت الظهر، على أساس ترفع القفص صدري
ظنًا منهم بأن الشهيق راح يصير أسهل
أول شيء سواه «كارل ستاوا» شال المخدات
وقام يفحص القفص الصدري بيده
وهو كان عنده فن أكثر ما هو علم
لأن للأسف ما قدر يعلم إلا شخص واحد بعده
كان سيء في نقل المعلومة
فالآن باقي واحدة، إذا ماتت، ما في علم «كارل ستاو»
انتهت
إي، فكان يحط يديه على القفص الصدري
ويشوف شلون يتوسع، لاحظ أن أغلب...
القفص الصدري عند الناس اللي عندهم أنفازيما مرتفع من الأمام
فأول شيء سواه، شال المخدة، وركز معهم على الزفير
وابتكر طريقة بأن المراجع يقدر يطلع الزفير بشكل أكبر
عن طريق العد وقت الزفير
فأنا الحين لما أتكلم، أطلع زفير
بس إذا كررت شيء بشكل متواصل، هنا راح أطول الزفير عندي
فيقول لهم: عدّوا من واحد للعشرة بصوت مهموس
ولكن بنفس الوقت مسموع شوي، متواصل
فقاموا، واحد واثنين وثلاثة وأربعة...
ويطول، ويعيدها
بعد شهر أو شهرين المرضى هذيل قاموا يقومون ويمشون ويصعدون
ويأكلون بشكل أكثر لأن التنفس صار أفضل
وأخذ هذه التجربة «كارل ستوا» طبقها على الفريق الأولمبي
أتوقع في الـ 1968 مع فريق العدائين
وهو الفريق الوحيد، هذيك السنة اللي ما استخدم أكسجين
وحققوا كلهم ميداليات
لو تذكر في صورة شهيرة في الأولمبيات
اللي الفائزين كلهم سمر، ورافعين إيدهم فوق على حركة النمر الأسود
هذا «كارل ستاوا» درّبهم على التنفس
فالتنفس السمعي هو استخدام هذه الأرقام
واحد واثنين وثلاثة وأربعة وخمسة وستة وسبعة وثمانية وتسعة وعشرة
تكرار بشكل مستمر، على أساس أطول الزفير كثر ما أقدر
ولما أطول الزفير عضلة الحجاب الحاجز يصير فيها إطالة
لأن عضلة الحجاب الحاجز تنقبض مع الشهيق
فإذا طولت الزفير يصير فيها إطالة
وكلما سويت فيها إطالة كلما صار فيها كفاءة أكثر في الانقباض
فهذا أستخدمه أنا مع المراجعين على أساس أطول الزفير
ولما أطول الزفير يتفعّل عندي العصب الحائر
اللي هو يأمر الجسم في الاسترخاء
ويفرز مضادات الالتهاب، ويحسّن من الـ«إتش آر في»
معدل تغير دقات القلب عندي، ويحسّن من الهضم واللعاب
كلها هذا بسبب...
أيش علاقة النفس بالهضم والأكل؟
من خلال العصب الحائر نفسه
إذا أنا في وضع مشحون، مو وقته أهضم
طاقتي لازم تروح لمواجهة هذا الضغط
فالطاقة راح تهدر على دقات القلب
الهضم يبطئ واجد لما أكون أنا مضغوط
عجيب والله
نعم، فتشوف ارتباط ما بين الضغط وعسر الهضم
أعزك الله، مشاكل في الخروج
لأن أنا في وضعية ما هي مرتاحة، فوظائفي وأنا مرتاح ما راح تكون سليمة
صح، الله يعطيك العافية
الله يعافيك
شكرًا جزيلًا
عفوًا، حيّاك الله
شكرًا لكم
شكرًا لأيمن الحمادي في إعداد الحلقة
محمد نور شمت في التحرير
وهّاب موسى في التصوير
وفي التسجيل الصوتي: عبدالعزيز المزي
والهندسة الصوتية: محمد الحسن
والتلوين: عبدالمجيد العطاس
وفي إدارة محتوى التواصل الاجتماعي: نورة السبيعي
وفي إدارة تحرير البرنامج: أسيل باعبدالله
هذا فنجان، أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع
ننشر كل الإنتاج بحب، من مدينة الرياض
الأسبوع المقبل، ألقاكم
خالصين جذي؟
خالصين جذي
ممتاز، يا أخي خفيف ولطيف بالـ...
حبيبي
لا، أنت لازم أسولف معك شوي
أنت طال عمرك، توني أقول حق الشباب
متابعك من 2019 حلقة «العجيري» أول حلقة
بعدين «الدويس» اللي هي لازم يكون في لها جزء ثالث، إن شاء الله
صحيح
وقلت شغلة، غيّر مسار حياتي، يمكن قلتها أنت وكانت جملة عابرة
بس أثّرت فيني واجد
وغيرت كل مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي عندي، وكل اللي أقدمه
قلت شغلة اللي هي...
ليش ما في، كان الموضوع عن المحتوى العربي
فقلت: يا أخي أيش ذنب المجتمع العربي أنه ما يعرف لغة إنقليزية؟
أنا مولود في وطن ومجتمع عربي
فالمفروض أن يكون في محتوى عربي
حزتها كان كل محتواي بالإنقليزي، قمت قلبته كله
فأشكرك على هذه النقطة جدًّا جميلة، الله يعطيك العافية
الله يسعدك، يارب